if you look at dots individual
happenings they look a certain way but
you start to connect them and you see
the pattern President Kennedy and
Governor John Connally have been cut
down by assassin's bullets in downtown
Dallas plane has crashed into one of the
towers on offense s of Wales has been
killed in a car accidents assassinations
are not just made to happen they have to
be allowed to happen
what do you think happened with Kennedy
he was taken out for a number of reasons
one of them was that he wasn't keen on
going into the full-blown Vietnam War if
you said to most people it still is most
people how many buildings came down on
9/11 let's say to go on the internet and
you put in building 7 collapse or
whatever you will see the most obvious
controlled demolition you'll ever see
there's some people who think that they
were drawn or absolutely oh god yes
there were 84 cameras in and around the
Pentagon which we've never seen
Princess Diana do you alluded to the
fact that you thought she was murdered
she knew literally and symbolically
where the bodies were buried for a star
and she was becoming bigger than the
royal family and and I go back to it she
knew their secrets the police knew about
Savile they knew what he was doing but
for some reason he wasn't nailed and he
wasn't nailed because he was a procurer
of children for the rich and famous and
therefore his back was watched and he
stayed in the inner circle of the
British royal family all the way through
almost to the end of his life the world
is controlled by basically a spider's
web the cement that holds this web
together is pedophilia and Satanism
[Music]
all right welcome back to the true
Geordi podcast today's guest is David
Icke Wow welcome Thanks wait a felis
round of applause I feel like we should
I've basically wanted to get David on
the podcast ever since we started the
podcast cuz I'm a bit of a a watcher of
conspiracy documentaries and you're one
of the leading guys in the country if
not one of the biggest guys in the world
I think you're a pro you are termed a
professional conspiracy theorist a lot
of people say that no yeah I am I'm a
dispersity researcher right and where
did where did this theory idea where did
this theory theorist idea come from
which is now just parroted has
overwhelmingly a label of dismissal
hours expiry theories where did it come
from
came from the CIA mmm in the 1960s some
very strange people very weird people
were not buying the official story of
the Kennedy assassination which included
a magic bullet which went through
several people and an out at crazy
angles they weren't buying that there
were really ridiculous people anyway it
started to get traction because the
official story of the Kennedy
assassination didn't make sense to lots
of people especially when someone's hit
in the forehead as there's a brooder
film taken by an onlooker showed and he
was supposed to have been shot by
someone behind him so you turn bullets
is that what we're doing now anyway it
started to get traction with people and
the CIA wanted to shut it down and and
the document actually exists you can see
it on the internet they contacted major
media organizations in America 1967 and
urged them to use the terms conspiracy
theorist and conspiracy theory to
discredit those that weren't buying the
official story of the Kennedy
assassination and all these decades
later you've got people in the
mainstream media in all its forms Oh
still using it as a form of dismissal
and discrediting with no idea whatsoever
that they are parroting a CIA operation
to discredit people that weren't buying
its lies
basically this is one of the few times
where I could start a podcast and just
literally I think we could do 10
podcasts review because you just know so
much stuff me it's mental out of
interest who do you think yeah what do
you think happened with Kennedy cuz I
don't know if I heard you spit on that
oh well I mean he was it was taken out
for a number of reasons one of them was
that he wasn't keen on going into the
full-blown Vietnam War and his Vice
President Lyndon Johnson was an asset of
this cabal that I've been exposing all
these years and the moment that Kennedy
was shot Johnson became president on the
plane and then reversed all the things
that this cabal wanted first what you
had was the the explosion of the Vietnam
War and and many other things the Nixon
did a hell of a lot after that to keep
[__] oh oh yeah because they wanted it
they want to stop the fire mind you have
you ever seen that the shootin the
footage yes what some of the most famous
foresee of all time not but I mean you
can see everything his brains are all
over ya wife climbing all over his wife
by the way though very good look and
Morgan wasn't sure I'm sure that was
part of the conspiracy there it's an
interesting wasn't it because I guess
then you go back to who well who did it
who are the people who well I've spent
30 years on covering that and written
book after book and I've been taught the
new about either way for those wondering
the trigger yeah
this every night this is this is about
9/11 how what a large part of how it was
done the fact the official story is
absolute garbage and basically the
network that did it and he went six
nineteen hijackers who were the Islamic
fanatics and that fits perfectly into
thirty years of work because the same
network that I've been uncovering for so
many other things including the Kennedy
assassination were those behind 9/11 so
I know there's gonna be so much detail
in there that we yeah we could just go
on enough I've got great the official
story to my knowledge is the steel
structure I was weakened due to the
fires caused by the
I'm just Lilia the will to forget and it
collapsed because of the weakened beams
or what are your if we were to say what
your main problems with the official
story what what what do you think oh
I've got enormous problems if if you
think of you know like a centipede I've
used this analogy this week a couple of
times and each of the legs is an aspect
of 9/11 did part of the story part of
the claim every single leg has got an
Achilles heel something that shows that
the official story can't be true and we
have the probably the most obvious
Achilles heel is building seven you know
about building seven yeah well you may
do but enormous numbers of people
worldwide don't for those who dawn
building 7 was the third year thing that
came in on that day if you said to most
people it's still his most people how
many buildings came down in 9/11 they'd
say - yeah in fact there was a court
case in New York where it was related to
9/11 and the subject of building seven
came up and the judge actually asked
what's building seven right so building
7 was a 47 story steel frame building a
skyscraper yeah owned by Larry
Silverstein who owned it before he
bought the lease weeks before 9/11 for
the twin towers and if you go on the
internet and you put in like on YouTube
you put in building 7 collapse or
whatever you will see the most obvious
controlled demolition you'll ever see
you know where you see from time to time
these buildings are brought down so the
charges are in the building in specific
sequences so that when they go off the
building falls on its own footprint and
up banging other buildings right and
most people think that takes that that
takes weeks to say I'm going to come to
that because that's very relevant to -
the obvious lies that we've been told
about building 7 so what was the
official store
building sir well wait for this first of
all in the whole history of engineering
and architecture and building history a
steel frame building has never fallen
before or since because of fire and the
official story is that this 47-story
steel frame building fell because of an
office furnishings fire that's the
official frickin story now um the fact
that it was a controlled demolition he
didn't mean to say this he got caught
with his pants down as well as on fire
came with an interview that Larry
Silverstein did it was like a
retrospective on PBS public service
broadcasting in America of 9/11 and he
was asked about his memories of that day
in September the 11th 2001 and he talks
about building seven and he said this I
quote him word for word in the book it
is an extraordinary quote he said um
well he said you know the fire commander
came to me that afternoon because
building seven didn't was not hit by a
plane and it fell at 5:20 in the
afternoon and he said well the fire
commander came to me and he he said you
know we're struggling to cope with the
fire in building seven and he said I
said to him you know there's been such a
tragic loss of life today um let's just
pull it and we agreed to pull it and and
then shortly afterwards he said we uh we
watched the building come down right Wow
now you just hit on it straight away two
things first of all fire commanders well
actually three start with number one
that fire commander in this mythical
exchange has never ever come forward and
said you hired that conversation no
one's ever said that yeah I had that
conversation with it and I have been
asked number two is that you don't pull
buildings
with fire departments you pulled them
with professional controlled demolition
experts and three-point you made you
take weeks putting the charges in the
right place for the building to fall on
its own footprint and here's Larry
Silverstein with what barefaced cheek
doesn't even begin to cut it saying that
they had this conversation and not long
afterwards that afternoon that the
building came down but there's another
thing the official investigation into
9/11 called the 9/11 Commission
first of all Bush and Cheney who were
running the White House actually Cheney
was not Bush they were force kicking and
screaming to even have an inquiry now
you've just had this monumental outrage
on American soil 3,000 people are dead
you would have surely the most
painstaking investigation into what
happened who did it so he would never be
able to happen again they fought to have
an inquiry at all then when they were
forced into it they appointed Henry
Kissinger as the guy to lead it which is
you know I mean it's it's just
extraordinary you couldn't think of
anyone more appropriate I mean you know
when Kissinger is lying cause his lips
are moving right and the right the way
through bloody history he says to him
he's been a front man for this cabal and
an insider of this cabal most of his had
oh bloody life anyway people didn't buy
that Kissinger and eventually had to
stand down Kissinger just looks evil as
well
well Kissinger has to stand down what he
was pressured to reveal his client list
of his company called Kissinger
associates now if he did reveal his
client list then that would have opened
a massive can of worms so he stood down
and so they then put a guy in charge
called
was keen but the key guy this is where
I'm going with this building seven the
key guy was a fella called
Philip Zelikow Philip Zelikow was a bush
inside a bush administration insider
wrote a book with Condoleezza Rice who
was Secretary of State at the time of
9/11 and he was put in charge of the
Commission as executive director and
people on the inside and even mainstream
journalists were saying
zelich hose running the whole thing in
fact it came out a year after the
Commission began that Zelikow and
someone else had written the headings
and the subheadings and basically the
outline of the final report before the
Commission had even met and paint my
numbers on them yeah and where I'm going
with this is that of course if you're
compiling a report explaining what
happened on 9/11 you have a bloody big
problem with building seven because
although the official story literally
staggeringly is that office furnishings
fire brought it down it's not credible
it's the speed of much akin oh yeah
isn't it it's if if this was engulfed in
flames like you see many buildings in
the past half B mmmm and then it came
that I mean even then it's still it's
still it's still it's not [__] going
anywhere but anyway the building seven
it wasn't even that on fire that much no
it wasn't when you watch the value the
fire was out by the time it came down it
barely I mean the Twin Towers at the top
obviously upwards their work they were
on fire but even still that does it to
pay him itself yeah as well but this
building seven is it looks fine and then
all of a sudden yeah ten seconds it's
gone the first two and a half seconds
that building fell was freefall speed
and you can only have freefall speed
when anything below has been removed
before it gets there so my resistance
yes again our dropping an apple from the
same height and impose that that's how
controlled demolitions work the lower
part of the building is gone before the
top part of the buildings
coming down this way kinda turns to dust
you know just to finish the point
Zelly co who was running an operation
literally to defend the official story
and keep out anything that challenged it
he had a problem with building seven
what do I do
I can't explain it and it's the most
obvious controlled demolition I quote in
the book a series of demolition experts
say see controlled demolition and so the
way got around it is he never mentioned
it mm-hmm can you imagine that
a commission report an official
Commission report into 911 three bill
and one of the three buildings coming
down isn't even for again mentioned why
because it's an Achilles heel and and
this is the point if they lied through
their teeth about building 7 which they
clearly did better a great organization
called architects and engineers for 9/11
truth as there are firefighters for 9/11
truth and pilots for 9/11 truth these
are organizations that were set up after
the attacks to challenge these
professionals in their field to
challenge the different aspects of the
story saying that couldn't have happened
I'll give you a quick one I just get
into the Twin Towers so I'll give you a
quick one on pilots for 9/11 truth and
the stuff they got out and other people
have got out as well flight 77 which was
supposed to fit the Pentagon the
official story is the pilot was a guy
called Annie Hanshaw right Annie Henshaw
was banned from hiring a one engine
plane six weeks before 9/11 because he
was so incompetent and dangerous in that
and these pilots who've come together
some of the pilots in pilots for 9/11
truth actually flew those planes they
were American Airlines United Airlines
pilots and they say that turn that that
spiral to hit the Pentagon so they claim
they couldn't have done the maneuvering
was that very very advanced a very
advanced I understand this all of the
pile
the people they'd been going to some
pilot school and one of the guys who was
at that pilot school was like these guys
were dog [__] they couldn't do dumb and
dumber it was one one flying
instructure's kind of description of
them but on the two the twin towers you
know we talked we just talked about
freefall speed those two towers were a
hundred and ten stories they fell in
freefall speed or 11 seconds of intense
but around that and meet mean figures
about ten but whose gives a second they
came down now what is the official story
that as the top fell it pancaked and
knocked all the others down right well
what happens with a pancake look
Explorer and slower and slower and yet
that whole building both buildings fell
in freefall speed so clearly it what and
the other thing is that if you look at
the the South Tower the second one the
big fireball right most of the the
aviation fuel fire the aviation fuel hmm
has burned away in the explosion outside
the building and there was out of that
point I don't show you aware there
something to tell you anything but that
jet fuel doesn't burn or certain exactly
would be required to melt the sea air
beams and on a diagram I watched there
was a video diagram of how it would have
happened the pancake theory yeah and you
see the the one floor hits the Mets 14 X
4 but there's a column of the middle
that is still standing area on the
diagram and that is never explained that
there the concrete went yeah the
concrete column or whatever it was at
the middle because that's where you
build those yeah but let's just take
that a step further none of that would
matter in a proper investigation yeah
because what you'd get our building
experts explosive experts all these
different kinds of experts relating to
what happened and they would go into the
rubble and they would look at the steel
they would look at the debris and they
would give you a bloody good idea why
those
buildings came down so how did they get
away with that the guy running the whole
9/11 criminal investigation was called
Michael Chertoff a real extreme ultra
Zionist who was the head of the criminal
division of the Justice Department he
oversaw the criminal investigation and
here he and his hierarchy agreed that in
ridiculously quick time all the rubble
in the steel from the twin towers and
building 7 would be taken in trucks that
were tracked every one of them by GPS
and if I'll give you one example one of
the truck drivers took a half an hour
extra for lunch and got fired right and
the reason they said that they did all
this was to was because of the sensitive
nature of the material they were
carrying well sensitive nature or the
other end they were dumped in to scrap
yards in New Jersey immediately cut up
put onto a ship's and shipped to Asia to
be smelted and to become someone's
bloody fridge and I quote in the book an
article in The New York Times at which
is just shows the contempt that this
cabal has for those who died and those
who whose loved ones were left behind it
describes this comical bizarre situation
where you've got building experts and
engineers at the scrap yards and it
describes how these big grabbers were
coming down picking up stuff and as the
grabbers went away these people were
running onto the onto the you know the
mound of of debris trying to see
anything that could give them any clue
about you know what happened and then
the bit the grabber would come back and
they'd run for their lives off it this
this is what went on this is a crime
scene I said
and police like just going and gone five
seconds to have a look it's not only a
crime scene but it's a crime scene that
they've shifted miles away from the
original crimes so it's like taking a
murder scene wiping up the blood and
then putting it somewhere else and go
and go and investigate
can I have one thing just like that
there will be people I know is upsetting
some people the subject of this and you
send the contempt with which a lot of
people treat the victims now haven't
you've dedicated the book I hope it was
worth saying because a lot of people go
it's disrespectful to discuss what
conspiracy theories surrounding 9/11 as
well just first people well I think the
disrespect also you look at the first
responders who I don't know anyone see
in the clip from the guy there's a
comedian who is speaking on behalf of
the first funders recession in a court
Jon Stewart he Islam busting the
courtroom gone you were filled all and
this fireman doctors nurses all of these
first responders behind they're being
tracked like [__] they've been dying
ever since because of what they breathed
in and George Bush told them it was safe
to go back yeah well yeah then the
Environment Department of the government
said it was safe to go back I've
dedicated the book not just to the those
who died and their loved ones left
behind who've been treated with absolute
contempt but also to all the millions
that have been killed and maimed in the
Middle East justified by that right when
we talk about this crime scene some of
the pictures I've seen before are of the
dead like the debris and you see where
these concrete beam sorry the steel
beams have been almost sheared it's like
sliced in oven you can see where what
looks like where the explosives would
have gone off because they've they've
just got them so perfectly it doesn't
just you're looking at a thing and how
would that have happened in a fire it
doesn't make sense yeah all well you
know again I quote in the book it took a
year for this to come out but they were
saying in that year that the fire crews
only got to a certain level not too high
in the towers right and then a year
after it happened
tapes were released of conversations
between fire officers
the ground and these fire officers were
right at the seat of the frickin fire
and they were talking about just little
pockets of fire to to deal with so that
the idea also started saying I heard a
bomb go off and I heard of quite a few
of them gone yeah there's you Young's in
there there's bombs in the building yeah
a few of them said yeah they said that
there's quite a few people in there that
I quote both from building seven and the
Twin Towers who independent of each
other
describe bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang going off as just before the towers
came down Wow yeah it's a but you know I
went when people see what's in that book
I mean I'm a I'm a bloke from Leicester
right and I do what I do but if I can do
that and take the fish'll story
absolutely apart in every aspect where
the hell of the BBC and CNN been in the
last 18 years where have they been
why is it that and I travel the world a
lot why have I never ever anywhere in
the world seen one mainstream media
documentary questioning the official
story
well you I wouldn't say predicted this
but you you made claims I think in the
early 2000 before this happened maybe in
late 90s I think was named year that a
terror attack in a major US city would
happen in order to to push it on yeah
it's a but basically 9/11 is a extreme
example of a technique that I've been
calling since the 1990s problem reaction
solution
it's the techniques that used on us all
the time you want to change the world in
a certain way and you want to push the
world in a certain direction you want to
do certain things which you know if you
just openly announced this is what we're
going to do all we want to do you'll get
a push back people go what do you mean
what are we going to do that for what
what's the justification of that like
regime change in a series of countries
in the Middle East and invading
Afghanistan
well nobody nobody ever wants to go to
war and I think there was a court wasn't
bush it was one of his P
who goes something like a new Pearl
Harbor there was a court that went round
where we need a new PA yeah I can give
you chapter and verse on that and that
alone is devastating to the official
story but you know if you if you look at
that whole area of the the new Pearl
Harbor there's a sequence that you can
pick up very clearly which I'll get to
in a second just to finish the thing on
problem reaction solution you first of
all instead of just openly announcing it
and you know you're gonna get pushback
you don't do that
you create a problem it could be a
terrorist attack it could be a war it
could be a run on a currency it could be
a government collapse anything that will
give you the opportunity to give the
solution to the problem you're creating
crucially you you name another villain
as soon as you can and bin Laden and
Afghanistan were being named literally
within an hour
that was amazing of all of him but God
like it's like you knew this guy was
such a [__] problem why is he [__]
able to do this yeah and even even on
extraordin analysis not like the blog
could be quotient because his name is
not worth much at the moment but he was
footage of him going though he named
Twin Towers he said you know what
surprise attack I mean no you're gonna
use bin Laden as the bogeyman like he
could he called a lot of them yeah
absolutely and you know it's an amazing
thing that bin Laden and Afghanistan
were named by a guy called he hood
Barack a former Israeli prime minister
he actually been Israeli Prime Minister
up until early 2001 on the BBC
immediately after the attacks he's
naming bin Laden and he's basically
calling for an invasion of Afghanistan
and these these things are all planned
because you create the problem and you
blame someone else for it and you've got
to get your villain in early so so that
villain then becomes the the official
story dominates who did it
and you're looking at stage to a problem
reaction solution with a reaction from
the public what you want them in fear
outrage and you want them to basically
say do something this can't go on what
they're gonna do about it
and then you who've covertly created the
problem and got that reaction then
openly offer the solutions to the
problems you've created and if we go to
what you mentioned there about a new
Pearl Harbor here's a sequence in 1979
the so called father of Israeli
intelligence a man called Issa her L
told an American journalist that he felt
that the Arab Arab terrorists were going
to target the biggest building in New
York because it was a phallic symbol and
that would in psychological terms help
to break the spirit of America in the
same year of 1979 Benjamin Netanyahu
started having conferences one in 79 one
in 1984 which American officials and
father George Bush attended in which he
was calling for a war on terror and
calling for the removal of Saddam
Hussein in Iraq in 1996 a man called
Richard Perle who was an ultra Zionist
close associate of Netanyahu who was by
then Prime Minister of Israel he
produced a report called a clean break
for Netanyahu in which he called for the
removal of Saddam Hussein targeting
Syria targeting Iran and so on and then
in 1997 an organization with Richard
Perle involved heavily was created in
America called the project for the new
American Century
this was an ultra Zionist Organization
which was co-founded by two big time
Israel first as an associates of
Netanyahu called William Kristol and
Robert Kagan in the project the new
Americans
century in 1997 when it was formed and
right up and across 9/11 was Dick Cheney
the time of 9/11 would be de facto
president officially vice president
Donald Rumsfeld who would be 9/11
defense secretary Paul Wolfowitz who was
9/11 deputy defense secretary in the
real power in the Pentagon and doves
that Kaymer at the time of 9/11 was
comptroller of the Pentagon in charge of
that tire budget and there was another
guy there in the project an American
Century called John Bolton who has been
until he got got thrown out this very
week as we speak was was pushing Trump
into targeting countries that this
project the new American Century wanted
targeting so come back into the sequence
to 1998 when this organization wrote to
President Bill Clinton calling for an
invasion of Iraq to remove Saddam
Hussein you see what these people wanted
right come forward again to September
2001 year before 9/11 the project for
new American Century produced a report
calling for and it was a basically a
mirror of the clean break report and it
was written by these characters I've
just been talking about including this
Richard Perle who've done the the clean
break for Netanyahu and it called for
American forces to fight and decisively
win multiple theater Wars to regime
change in a series of countries Iraq
Libya Syria Lebanon Iran North Korea and
others and in this document it says this
process of transformation these regime
changes will necessarily be slow and
this is the quote absent some catalyzing
and catastrophic event like a new Pearl
Harbor
Yeah right and a few months later a very
few months later the people that wrote
that document yes a Kimes and yet
Cheney's and your Rumsfeld and yet wolf
Yvette's and your pearls came to power
in January 2001 with the Bush
administration and nine months later
America had what Bush called at the time
our Pearl Harbor the Pearl Harbor of the
21st century as a result of which ever
since they've been ticking off this this
list make no sense because officially
they weren't even involved in 9/11
anyway and the weapons of mass
destruction were obviously proved to be
a load of bollocks yeah just to put it
in the context or for maybe some younger
people who've never been exposed to your
work before the idea that a government
could allow this to happen to their own
people is unbelievable or hot look at
the heads around but this isn't this has
been happened in many times to mine so
what I've researched anyway I think
Hitler was at the Reichstag building
yeah right side building yeah yeah and
then actually some people actually say
that Americans knew about Pearl Harbor
before it huh oh absolutely they did
I've gone into that in in previous books
and some people have written whole books
about pearl harbors a lot America was
itching to get into the war yeah from a
government standpoint but that people
were like keep thus the [__] I tell it
very very quickly the background to that
Franklin Roosevelt won an election
before America entered the second world
war and his mantra was I tell you
mothers and fathers of America your boys
are not going into that war in Europe he
knows they are but he can't win by
saying so but he knows they are so what
they look for and this is how problem
reaction solution works they create an
excuse which gives them the excuse to do
what they wanted to do anyway but also
puts them in the clear because after the
Pearl Harbor attack by Japan which was
very clearly engineered
Franklin Roosevelt was like well you
know I didn't want to go in that war in
Europe but we can't have this and and
people gone yeah well I understand that
for ankling yeah we've gotta go yet
problem reaction solution works from
that standpoint if we're looking at 911
after all the research you've done them
but maybe we could do the Pentagon first
because there's a lot wrong with that as
well where's the footage that had odd
cameras the age of 84 ways I've come but
the remains of the plane as well yeah
because if I'm right thing and half of
the plane just didn't even show up well
let me just explain this you know there
is a question over a massive question I
say absolutely justified about whether a
plane hit the Pentagon at all for many
of the reasons you've already mentioned
plus a lot more and and and the official
reaction is well that's that's
ridiculous that's a conspiracy theory
well okay there were 84 cameras in and
around the Pentagon filming that day
which I know and I saw in the book the
FBI came and took away that morning
which we've never seen if a plane hit
the Pentagon many of those cameras are
going to have it on so just show up but
they know they never know never have and
the other thing is this do you know it's
never been established isn't there a
fort to grow far to four-cross with oh
yeah but why French oh yes a joke and
you're like that doesn't look like a far
far distance yeah it looks more like a
missile yeah exactly what this very good
chance it was it miss some it either a
missile or a bomb inside the building
because well god I mean we could talk
forever about this has so many elements
to it you know the size of the Pentagon
right massive massive building well on
the far side from where the Pentagon was
said to be here that's where all the
bigwigs were your Rumsfeld's and your
big generals right now if you're oh and
by the way if the play-doh did to come
straight in that's where it would have
hit but I had to do this spiral and and
by doing the spiral and missing where
the bigwigs were and if you did any
research on the Internet you knew where
they
and the guy flying inside now yeah
Johnny does let's hit the cleaners room
yeah yeah we do need to do another
circle make you're gonna hit the
Rumsfeld I'm having amir here it comes
round one furnace it comes round they
say and it hits something called wedge
one which one just happened to be that
part of the pentagon that had just
undergone massive reinforcement to
protect the building from just such an
attack it's just insane but like I was
saying do you know that they've never
even established and it's a doddle to do
that the planes that left the airports
were the ones that hit the buildings
there's a lot of a lot of talk about
yeah because there was some people who
said who seen the planes going to the
building actual Twin Towers who said
they did not look like regular Airlines
they looked like friends they look
different but I mean that's respect
elation well what is that is the footage
of 9/11 there's some people who think
that they were drones
I don't know their work about that I
absolutely I absolutely I've been set up
and saying for a long long time now many
many years going way back that they were
they were drones and I'll give you a
story in a second which will show that
that was planned in 1962 never mind I at
2001 but what I was going to say with
this thing is that every single plane
crash in the world no matter what it is
they establish that the plane is the one
they think it is yeah and they do it
this way all plane parts have a serial
number and there are some called time
change parts which are changed regularly
even if there's nothing wrong with them
they have to be changed and they all
have serial numbers and every time a
part is put on a plane
the maintenance log logs the serial
number so what the plane investigators
do every time not when there's an R in
the month every time is they take the
maintenance logs and they look at the
parts that have been found and they say
yep they match this is that this is
definitely the plane we think it is that
was not done on 9/11 on
of the four planes and someone put in a
Freedom of Information Act request to
the FBI to reveal the documentation to
show that that's been done and the FBI
came back and said the documentary a
documentation doesn't exist because it
was not done and they said it wasn't
done because the identity of the planes
was never in doubt now people that read
the book they'll say they'll see that
the identity of the planes was massively
massively in doubt so again just like
the cameras okay what about black boxes
do with sorry yeah well the black boxes
have serial numbers well they were they
recovered some of them were some of them
were none were recovered from the Twin
Tower so they claim although some some
people that were you know working in the
rubble have that people who run so there
was people on the planes who were
ringing their relatives that was one
thing I always was like confused about
like wow those people know when I try
and use my phone on a million I can't
use it
oh well depends on the atmosphere yeah
no but I I'm not dispute this isn't me
coming from a conspiracy uncle anything
it I just always thought well that
because recently they apparently brought
new technology yeah it's gonna allow us
to ring people on a plane I'm like well
now it's be really annoying
yeah well they let me pick up that point
before it disappears the stories of the
calls from the plane are extremely in
doubt especially when you're looking at
the technology of 2001 in terms of cell
phones and you know this is this is what
happened with for fortune everything I'm
saying here by the way is all supported
by factual detail in the book when the
story first broke the basically FBI
media story was that all these kind of
phone calls were made from cell phones
from the planes run then it was pointed
out something you just mentioned hold on
a minute
you can't you can't make a cell phone
calls from that from that altitude right
and so what happened then is the FBI
changed the story and started saying no
they they came from seatback phones
known as air
which they used to have in those days I
used one one occasion about the same
time actually and there were in the
seatbacks and you they had a wire on and
you pulled them out and you used a
credit card and you could call the
ground they're called air phones or run
by a company called Vera's on and so
suddenly these cell phones became air
phones but two things to that first of
all a lady called Barbara Olson who was
a envision contributor to CNN she was
married to the Bush administration
Solicitor General called Ted Olson and
the official story is she was on flight
77 and she made two phone calls to her
husband at the Justice Department and
they and told him what was going on on
the plane it's from those phone calls
alleged phone calls that the whole idea
of box cutters came from it's well it
came from and the only evidence if you
can call it evidence that flight 77
turned around in the Midwest and came
back and it wasn't another plane was the
Olson calls oh really
those Olson calls have no supporting
documentation either at her end or the
Justice Department's end that they were
and as though made the one of the things
so in that to my knowledge
was there any recordings of the puffs at
the plant or anything as only proof like
that I mean there are recordings well
yeah yeah yeah but again you know it's a
long story but in the book I I go
through all this background about you
know what was actually going on it could
have been going on but here's the point
the official story was that first of all
was that Barbara Olson caught her
husband on a cell phone and then you
look at the flight data recorder and and
it impossible so the story changed and
that's what you find with it the 9/11
story which I've been tracking literally
since the day it happened brought out
the first book on it in 2002 when
they're caught out the story changes so
suddenly it became no she called on an
air phone that's how she did it
well as I quote from the American
Airlines because it was an American
seven five seven flight 77 are so quote
from the American Airlines manual and
from also pilots and cabin staff of the
time the air phones have been taken out
of American seven 5/7 by the time of
9/11 so they weren't African Air phones
that's right telephone calls will be
lost
yeah illusion is another one there was a
passenger on flight 93 called Tom
Burnett and he called his wife and his
wife saw his cell phone number come up
on her phone so he's called her on his
cell phone and then according to the
flight data recorder when he called her
the plane was flying at between
thirty-four thousand forty thousand feet
so the story changed and in the official
explanation the FBI said he called on an
air phone which were still in United
Airlines planes which was not was not
the call log but his cell phone number
came out of another thing a couple of
the callers one particular guy could
Todd Beamer he was the let's roll guy
and this great doubt about whether he
actually said that yeah that sounds
great for a movie time yeah was like
nineteen ninety three all right I'd be
interested what he didn't call his wife
although he could have done because the
operator offered to put him through but
he stayed on the line to this operator a
lady called Lisa Jefferson a Vera's
on-air phone operator for a long long
time and she said first of all it was
absolutely amazing because air phone
calls were going down all around me was
chaos because that the connections were
breaking down everywhere but he is never
broke down something else because she's
a air phone expert works it all the time
she said that when the line breaks
there's a squealing sound right
well that phone
connection between her and Todd Beamer
as is claimed continued long long long
after the plane was supposed to have
crashed and another caller some parents
and taking a call from from that their
relative the same thing happened the
call continued after the plane was
supposed to have crashed and of course
the air phones get their power from the
power of the plane so the plane crashes
it's all down the other thing Todd
beamers cell phone had nineteen outgoing
calls made on it after that plane was
supposed to have crashed I mean all over
the place there are these extraordinary
things that cannot be explained and none
of it was explored in the 9/11
Commission report because they can't
explain it so what are we then saying
happened to those people the goners
because they were throw real people
aren't they yeah let me let me give you
a some background to something called
Operation Northwoods and Chris Operation
Northwoods was basically a version of
9/11 in 1962 and then you can you can
see that the themes which includes
passengers in 1962 during the Kennedy
assassination
there was a plan made to discredit
Castro and Cuba to justify an invasion
notice the the common theme and it was
called Operation Northwoods and this is
not me
theorizing and pulling out the ether I'm
quoting now the official American
archive and in the summer of 2001 a
former ABC investigative producer called
James Bamford came out with a book
called body of secrets it was it was an
investigation into the National Security
Agency in America at the NSA and in that
research he came across this these
documents in the archive Operation
Northwoods and it was a plan and in the
end when Kennedy found out about it
apparently he said you must be joking
and it wasn't played out but it was all
planned to be played out and there was a
guy who was head of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff the
at the uniform level of the military in
the Pentagon called Lemnitzer in he was
orchestrating it all and this is what it
says in these documents the plan was to
stage terrorists bomb and other attacks
in major American cities New York Miami
were two of those that are named to have
American military forces covertly sink
American shipping and to blame the
attacks on Castro and Cuba to justify an
invasion of Cuba now this is the this is
the big connection to 9/11 one of the
things they plan and it's described in
detail in the documents was that they
were going to pick a plane flying a
commercial route from an East Coast
American Airport whose natural route
took it over at very high altitude
obviously Cuban airspace and they were
going to put on the plane passengers and
this is a quote from the document with
carefully selected aliases and the plane
was going to fly down across Florida
going down towards Cuba and when it got
into Florida another plane the same type
painted in the same airline colors a
drone controlled from the ground we're
talking 1962 what ding taluk technology
they have in 2001 was going to take off
from the Eglin Air Force Base it was
gonna go up close to the original plane
so that basically the blips became one
and then the plane that left the airport
with the carefully selected alias
passengers was going to be landed at
Eglin Air Force Base the drone was going
to go on the the scheduled route and it
was going to be blown up by radio signal
over Cuba and it even says in the
document and we will wait for the in
to national aviation authorities to tell
us what has happened to obviously keep
keeping the idea that it we had nothing
to do with it so that's what they
planned in 1962 this is all [__] this
is this is in the American official
spark I've operational caught this
before as well because it does add a lot
of weight as what you're seeing them
yeah so what was the plan with those
people who are on the plane that it
wasn't said what happened to them
afterwards but the point is if the
original passengers were on these planes
and I'll tell you something else that
happened and how they could lose them in
a second if they were on those planes
well do you think they want him around
to tell their story of course not right
but let me let me just say this you
people have come across this but the
vast majority people will not have done
on 9/11 on that day of all days there
was what was described as an
unprecedented number of war games going
on in the skies where the 9/11 hijackers
would explain what war games are do
practice scenarios where the military
and the Air Force are practicing what
they would do in the case of hijackings
and threats to America from the sky
there was a long list of them I list
them in in the book a long list of them
and never before have so many been
concentrated at the same time 9/11 one
of the one of the scenarios they were
playing out why these hijacks were going
on was of a plane hitting the National
Reconnaissance Office in in Washington
DC and by the way when they're playing
out these war games they employ actors
and actresses to play out roles for
instance in the National Reconnaissance
scenario
there were there was smoke bombs going
off to simulate the building being hit
there were people in on the staff that
had scripts to follow in reaction to it
and there were people in the building
given phone calls to make with scripts -
what's interesting what's interesting
just going back to the phone calls
briefly is the phenomenal common theme
from people at the other end of the
phone calls that people the people were
incredibly calm they couldn't believe it
they didn't hear any call going off of
the background often they didn't really
hear plain noises and and as one wife of
a passenger said he talked to me
describing that these these these
hijackers were doing this and the other
he talked to me as if as if he was
calling me from the office at work it
just never I if you have one like that
or - fair enough but there was a stream
of them and so these war games were
going on now on the other the reaction
system - hijackings or attacks from the
air in America
is orchestrated by an organization
called NORAD at the air force
organization and their reaction Center
with regard to 9/11 was a place called
Rome in New York State and I published
some of the you know the the record of
the tapes of the of what was going on
what they were saying and when the first
reports came in of the planes being
hijacked they were saying well well one
of them so I thought the war games must
have started early right and they were
asking is this real or is this scenario
completely confused them but there's
something else on their screens and on
the screens of air traffic controllers
were simulated planes that didn't exist
it's a system they call sim over live so
you've got your live planes and then
you've got your simulated planes
and it was done on purpose to create
total confusion in 1999 a golfer called
Payne Stewart took off in a private
plane with some friends heading to
Dallas and when they got to a certain
height there was a decompression problem
and everyone kind of conked out so the
planes flying on its own everyone's
unconscious within no time the
air-traffic controller is contracted
NORAD which is absolutely the
regulations if you think there's any
problem contact NORAD that's in the
regulations NORAD has immediately
scramble planes they're going alongside
it then other planes come up as it goes
through what they're doing is they're
seeing if there's any life in the plane
inside the plane but they're also making
sure that when this plane runs out of
fuel if it's going to fall on a civilian
area or a built-up area a populated area
they're gonna take it out and that
happened with Payne Stewart's private
jet very well-documented the Chiefs of
Staff in the Pentagon as the media
reported were tracking the plane all the
way through this is the golfer's plane
on 9/11 in a period of two hours there
was not one reaction from the American
Air Force military that made any
difference whatsoever because there was
a stand down ten miles down the road
from the Pentagon is the Andrews Air
Force Base this is where Air Force one
comes in out all the foreign leaders
come in and out that's immensely well
defended but um on 9/11 they didn't
scramble planes from ten miles down the
road Andrews
they scrambled over from the Langley Air
Force Base 151 hundred thirty miles away
for New York they scrambled in Cape Cod
153 miles away and the whole common
theme was Oh
didn't get there quite in time in fact
in fact the when the planes were
scrambled from the Langley base
supposedly from flight 77 but it turned
out to be something else actually they
never the pilots the two pilots said
they never told us what we were being
rambled for let's not forget by that
time the twin towers have been hit so
what they thought they said is that I'm
being scrambled as per Cold War scenario
from it for an attack from the Atlantic
so here's Washington here's Langley they
went out into the Atlantic right before
turnaround and coming back and and of
course the Pentagon was hit before they
they got there and and the moment and
this is a big theme in 9/11 until the
Pentagon was hit once the Pentagon was
it some some of the normal reaction
things started to happen but not until
and there's another time most of it on
yeah yeah exactly
and there's another common theme which
is people lying about what they were
doing
before the Pentagon was hit which gave
them a cover story for why they were not
able to react and once the Pentagon was
hit as the mainstream media reported at
the time they scrambled planes from
Andrews ten miles down the road to
protect the skies above Washington
another thing at Washington and many
tenants say the World Trade Center - is
within a no-fly zone called peace 56 and
it's basically based around the
Washington Monument and and there's a
Innis section there's an middle sections
an out section apparently and I quote in
the book
a former US defense secretary Caspar
Weinberger who was asked about the
no-fly zone and he said well this is how
it works
he said Washington is ringed with air
bases among them is Andrews Air Force
Base and if any plane goes in to the
no-fly zone without the code that gives
it permission to fly there then it's
taken out right I quote insiders of the
Pentagon who worked at the Pentagon and
this is obvious anyway describing how
the Pentagon is defended by
ground-to-air missiles I mean it would
be wouldn't it home of the American
military so that means basically that
they're ready to go
yeah straight
yeah go inside you down where were they
on 9/11 and I contacted because when I
was writing my first book come Alice
Wonderland in the World Trade Center
disaster I was in contact with the FBI
with the Federal Aviation Administration
and NORAD all of them and I asked them
who police's the no-fly zone over
Washington then and they never gave me
an answer of how it's done
because if they had have done then a
whole can of worms opens so where we
where was that reaction system on 9/11
because you know you you what's the
point of a no-fly zone if it's not
defended you know and and so if you are
highly professional hijackers which is
what we're supposed to believe you can
go on the internet and you can find this
stuff out you can find the reaction
times just just follow the Payne Stewart
story and yet flight 77 we are asked to
believe was flown 40 minutes out into
the Midwest and then turn round and
flown back at no / 18 minutes it was in
the air 40 minutes after it was known to
be quote hijacked and there was no
response from the American military that
is normally up there in no time a
hundred and twenty five times in the
previous year there were questions about
planes boom they're up there but not on
9/11 because it was it was a stand down
because there was a guy called Leroy
Fletcher Prouty he wrote books on the
Kennedy assassination he was a big-time
intelligence military government insider
in fact one of the characters in the
movie JFK was apparently based on him he
died in just before 9/11 actually and he
was describing assassinations but of
course this fits perfectly as well and
he said if you want to know who was
involved in an assassination look who
had the who had the power and used it to
remove the normal security was that
Goodfellas in it yeah I'm the calm
yeah like removing the the normal
security systems because as he pointed
out assassinations I in like 911 - don't
just are not just made to happen they
have to be allowed to happen because
otherwise the normal security responses
would stop them happening so you have to
stand them down that sort of brings me
onto a question because we got so much I
want to talk to you about so to sort of
cut off 911 in a way because you've done
so much in this book and people can get
it if they want to really get every
detail but when you say allowed to
happen are we saying because there was a
huge 9/11 was an inside job movement
yeah for a while after that I think
there's a difference between being an
inside job and being allowed to happen
as some people speculate that Pearl
Harbor was allowed to happen where do
you sell all all of the above it was
both made to happen and allowed to
happen I I named the the people involved
in making app and and allowing a
champion did you have a problem with
getting those names in the book at all
or anything like that was then oh I
published my own books right and there
was but I mean in terms of people
threatening legal action there's no
nobody ever does with you the point the
point is this they they have they spent
and I document this in the book as well
they've spent 18 years making sure this
never gets too cool hmm they don't want
an open court in which this stuff can be
openly kind of put in the public arena
in fact I show how the judges were
specifically and they all will have a
connection were appointed to stop the
families you see the families were
offered compensation but the
compensation came with the rider you'll
get the money but but you agree and
taking the money you don't take any
civil action well around a hundred
families had sod that for a game of
soldiers we won our day in court and and
let's have the evidence out and there
was a particular judge it was called
Alvin Hellerstein and he has connections
to all these other people
who
ran what was described as a war of
attrition making it harder and harder
for them to get to court and the last
one of the nearly a hundred are pulled
in 2011 and the New York Times run a
story which said that a decision by
Hellerstein on the litigation has now
made it impossible for these people to
win so they pulled and taking the
conversation so they kept it all out of
court another quick thing on 9/11 and
the the question is that whenever
there's a hijack the first thing that
pilots are told to do they punch in a
four digit code it literally takes that
long right every time and then on the
ground they know this a hijack right not
one of those four planes put in the
hijack code you know I was really
strange as well is if if the official
story was true it was one strange lie
that was told by George Bush and he goes
I've seen their first plane going
exactly terrible pilot yeah he goes but
then the second plane goes in and I knew
like yeah but then yeah he was acting as
if on the day yeah we've watched the
first plane go in and then the second
plane when Fahrenheit 9/11 he says no
but nobody we didn't have any foot in
our first plane going in until it lay
until later the second plane was videoed
by everyone because there was obviously
cameras by that time on the twin towers
and in my head I'm like well why are you
[__] lie in their bathroom wasn't he
there's foot even Fahrenheit 9/11 yet
yeah very sweet president really so he
obviously wasn't watching any [__] TV
well they were supreme winning that's
what the Pirtle are you about I know it
makes you look even more guilty
I tell him that I'm in America at the
time right after 9/11
it's very shortly after 9/11 and I'm in
a bar you know as you are and I'm
watching CNN on the bar television and
and they're running a live Town Meeting
which which in American terms is
basically a public meeting as we would
call it and Bush is answering questions
from the audience all very carefully
placed questions of course and this kid
stood up his name was Jordan and he
asked him
bush what what he did that day what
happened what was he doing that day and
he said well Jordan he said I knew I was
the commander in chief and I had to act
what he didn't did he really I mean they
kept him out his book though but then
I'm watching this live on this this
Senate Elliott in the bar and he even
tells that story he said just before he
went into the Clark classroom to read a
story about a pet goat he saw on a
television in a back room at the school
in Florida the first plane hit and he
said what a terrible pilot right and
then he goes in to the classroom and
then Andrew card his chief of staff came
in on the famous pictures and and said
the second planes hit so he's talking
about the first plane and as you rightly
say there was no live footage of the
first plane that was caught by a camera
crew doing a documentary on on the fire
department as took a couple of days yes
absolutely it did and so what I'm doing
the next morning I'm scouting the papers
and I'm watching the news in America and
I'm waiting for someone to say what was
he talking about nothing and I thought
did I hear it right and then up about
two weeks three weeks later a visitor to
my web site in Belgium sent me a link to
the official White House you know
government archive thing in which they
had the entire transcript of that town
meeting on the official and and there it
was he said it and and it just asked us
asked ourselves we have a media peopled
by people that claim to be journalists
and they didn't pick up as you picked it
up so blatantly bloody obvious it's
ridiculous but what would happen to them
if they don't it you know much of Jordan
when you're talking [__] yes
yeah yes I kind of want to talk to you
about the stock okay start with the
journey okay
911 is important but for you a lot of
people would know how this all happened
for you you're a footballer Coventry
City goalkeeper you have to stop your
career early for the arthritis and you
ended up being a BBC reporter right and
at some point and I don't work very
weird well yeah at some point you were
like [__] this I don't want to do this
anymore
ABC sport does that too baby mop god
bless Mark Lawrenson
you know I mean but yeah but you know
and you were you're a figure of ridicule
or members-- when you first started
doing this and a lot of my respect for
you comes from going through all that
because whether people agree with you I
don't agree with everything you say
you [__] you faced the the [__] that
you got and you stood up for what you
think and what you believe in and you
didn't care what people say now can you
sort of describe what that was like to
go through because you weren't a young
guy when that sort of yeah there is
still the interview on YouTube by the
way they the first interviewing a lot of
people go back see it was the worgen in
the world but but I mean more like what
was it like going through everyone
laughing and what and yeah the the the
story about how it all came about is is
is long and I've told it before
iiiiii had some incredibly what you
might call paranormal they're not para
they're actually normal but their
paranormal compared with the human
perception of normal which is very
different to what is normal and so I I
it was like something happened to me and
like I said it's a long story about
built up you imagine that you're living
your life and you're living your life in
a bubble and within that bubble is your
reality and then someone comes along and
without any warning pops the bubble and
suddenly information concepts are
pouring into your conscious mind you
know in a way that's so massive it's
like pressing too many keys on a
computer the computer freezes our
cooperate
this information is too much and that
was lucky for me and for three months in
early 91 if you'd have asked me my name
and I checked because I had this
bombardment of information and concepts
and all these things that were happening
and then as eventually a computer goes
and freezes and weakens come back after
three months and of course the wagon
show was right in the middle of that
mm-hmm the computer unfroze and people
were saying some I thought you've gone
mad you're the same David I knew I've
always known I appear to be but it
wasn't I was the same basically I am now
but I saw the world completely
differently I could see how dots
connected instead of how things seem to
be random and apart from everything else
and my whole the whole thing changed but
you know I have this phrase I've used in
one or two of the books life tends to
give you your greatest gift brilliantly
disguised as your worst nightmare and
when I look back at that time because of
the Wogan show and all that stuff I got
the most extraordinary historic levels
of ridicule I can walk down the street
in Britain with yeah I don't think
people nowadays couldn't grasp stuff but
it's like trending on Twitter do you
know I mean yeah it's yeah but weird
learn again and and so I couldn't go
into a bar a comedian only had to say my
name no joke necessary and they got a
laugh and you'd think that was a
nightmare and it wasn't nice to
experience but you know what may it set
me free it set me free of the prison I
know a lot of young people watch this
and this podcast and I know a lot of
young people get really screwed up even
to the point of suicide because of what
said about them on social media and all
that stuff well most people live in a
prison called fearing what other people
think
and when you fear or you're concerned
about what other people think you are
not you anymore you are what you are
expected to be by those you don't want
abuse or criticism or ridicule from so
you conform to the norm so that you you
you're not called crazy you're not cool
you're not laughed at in the street or
laughed out at social media and all that
stuff and and you have gone you're now a
construct of someone else's version of
what you should be and most people are
not saying what they really believe
they're not living their life as they
really want to live it because they fear
what will other people think what all
the people at work think the people down
the bar what will my mother say and all
this stuff but when you are faced with
the scale of ridicule that I went
through you've got a choice you can end
up in the corner shaken or and I just
withdraw from the world or you can come
out honed in the fire and and not really
honed in the fire it's basically I know
exactly not becoming something so much
as letting go what was impression you
knew before which the fear of other
people think so when people ask me a
question I don't go through mental
gymnastics how do I put this in a way
these people will think I'm okay or
credible or sensible or intelligent or
something I won't think I'm mad I just
say what I feel and and if people you
know don't like it well they can do the
other thing that's quite fine with me
and it set me free and so you know I get
an enormous abuse on on the internet
stuff as well as enormous support now
but it goes in one ear and out the other
it doesn't affect me because what I
would say to you know young people are
affected by this you're the one with the
power the power is not with the abuser
it's with the receiver in how they
receive the abuse and you can you
can say you can fall apart because
they're saying this stuff about me and
that's a reaction to it that's going to
destroy you or you can say I don't give
a [__] I would say to these kids that's
very quickly you cannot you cannot
underestimate or no sorry overestimate
you cannot overestimate the power of not
giving a [__] because people are kept in
line they're kept in line in what they
say what they do by giving a [__] you
know people that get upset by what
people say about them online do so
because they give a [__]
people won't expose this death cult
which it is in the end that they're
freaking evil that I mean they make
Psychopaths look like looking you know
Mary Poppins these people but they won't
expose them because they fear the
consequences of exposing them I don't
give a [__] and therefore that's why
that books like that and and and other
people wouldn't write it because they
think well what the consequences may
write in this and and consequences
another prison that people live in
instead of doing what they feel to be
right and what they know to be right are
just doing it because I you know people
say called dear what do you think the
consequences are right in that book
we're gonna be I don't give a [__]
because if I if I consider consequences
of doing something that I believed to be
right I'm actually considering
compromising doing what I believe to be
right because have any consequences for
me no you do what you believe to be
right consequences are a prison because
if you all the time considering
consequences you're you'll always
persuade yourself there's a very good
reason not to do what you believe to be
right because the consequences seemed
too much for you to do to accept a lot
of people never never achieve their full
potential because they're worrying about
what everyone else absolutely and so
same as what you went through but I've
had a few people laughing and joking
about me recently
and it said one of the best things
that's ever happened I was like because
it's a one thing to not give a [__] yeah
it's another thing to really be tested
yeah it's that how little of a [__] you
give and when everyone's bluffing at
your point I say and [__] about you then
you really have to [__] prove it then
there's not many people come yeah and
weirdly I think everyone in their life
at one point or another would be
benefiting from that like get in that
experience because it just makes you the
best person you can be I get okay I'll
get this abuse thrown at me in this
ridicule and I'm like thanks for sharing
that with me have a nice day don't give
a [__] you know and wish you don't have
to you don't have to be affected by
other people you can choose not just
where you get your mental strength from
within you not from what other people
think you and tell you you are Zach
that's when abuse and praise just become
the soup and the same thing what in
that's a poem absolutely Kipling you
have Ruggeri those [__] two Impostors
just the same
that's exactly where 20 varsity bank
they are 20 postures you know you can
you can tell me I'm God's gift to the
world and you can tell me I'm a you know
a complete idiot and our soul and I'll
receive both in the same way we do live
in a time where there aren't many
solutions offer for that and some people
say your harbinger of doom or whatever
you know the kind of guy who just and I
complete and actually wearing what you
just said then and I'm not accusing you
that I see now why you feel you can say
those things but I guess the interesting
side to that for me is we are debasing a
lot of peope where a lot of people
derive their happiness from which would
be the idea of a family which is
responsibility towards others and the
idea of a collective Society which is
responsibility towards others and so
there has to be an element of giving a
ship for other people but I am often
left with a bit of a not an empty
feeling because I find you very
compelling but quite quite a well what's
the point then sort of feeling after I
hear a lot of what you say do you know
what I mean no no it's I mean I don't
mean that to get you I don't want one of
the things one of the major areas that
are right about is the nature of reality
and how our perceptions become our
experience mmm
so if you go into that level I write
enormous amount talking Norma's amount
about solutions hmm
because a few people control the human
race and the direction of the human race
because the human race has given its
power to those people
given its power away people are giving
the consciously or unconsciously both
you know they're given the their power
away to internet trolls I mean
III said the other day on the Internet
it's not you that needs the help it's
the trolls yeah you know I mean so what
do you think of this troll that said
this about what their orrible so what do
you let them affect you for then just
don't don't don't let them in but you
know you got someone to run your social
media yeah one does for me I've never
even seen the tweet moment and although
he's [__] is [__] debilitating for
me and Gio to the homeless sick of his
[__] yeah we take shifts the point
about not giving a [__] I mean let me
put that into context I write that book
and I've taken the [__] I've taken over
the last thirty years because I give a
[__] about other people about the world
and the way it's going and that
what-what the world that my
grandchildren children are going to live
in if we don't sort this out and
everybody else's children grandchildren
gee yes that's not that's not
necessarily what I'm saying that's yeah
but what I'm saying about not giving a
[__] is being affected what by what
people say and do with regard to you and
when you say when I said I don't give a
[__] I don't mean I'll just shut up I'm
not interested on this thing no not when
I'm not talking I spend most of my life
listening so I do listen to people and
sometimes you go you know that's bloody
valid that is of course you most of this
book is about listening to a PDF so so
you do that what we're not what I'm
talking about is a specific area of not
giving a [__] which is form of having
all having you affected from a mental
health point of view ever there's only
so much we can take on board from other
people I feel like there's a lemon where
you can take people's opinions but when
you know someone just ate a [__] hurt
you yeah it's like all right man
if you're giving kripp constructive
critics a play that's one thing that's
different
one thing you'd mention there sorry to
change subject again his children and
you were one of the first people a long
time ago to say that there was a
upper-echelon pedo ring full of Royals
and oh absolutely
oh god yes and and you know what at this
time when you were being laughed at you
know you were saying things like this
and now a lot of people looking at you
gone he was actually spot-on about this
we've got the Epstein thing going on now
look talk about that for ages yeah oh
yeah see we've got print what is it
which princess it who is living for it
Sandra Prince Andrei's good pictures um
there's so many elements to this but in
the end they all come together so if I
could just say this very quickly and
then then I can go into this this
subject the world is controlled by
basically a spider's web that it
spider's web is a brilliant symbol of it
you've got the spider at the center of
the web which is deep in the shadows you
you won't see them in the public arena
and then the strands in the web
immediately around the spider are the
most exclusive secret societies that's
where the people who really know what
the game is just operating a little more
not you well yeah well that's a lot of
it but but and I'm talking about that
forever as well but the the some of
these secret societies the real
exclusive ones next to the spider than
even of names so they are ordered to
track and then you've got to join as
well then it cuz you want to join there
and they go you've gotta say the name
yeah exactly yeah they don't even do
that at that level it's all it's all you
know real insider stuff and then you
come out still in the hidden and then
you hit your Freemasons and your Knights
of Malta your build up new example oh
yeah well I'm coming to them your your
the secret societies your inner core of
the Jesuit Order and when I say
Freemasons and these people I'm talking
about the inner core because secret
societies and indeed organisations
within society in general are
compartmentalized most Freemasons in the
world never get higher than the bottom
three levels of degree in the
the ones who call for a payment yeah 33
degrees of the Scottish Rite of
Freemasonry they don't know what's going
on in the IRS Long's you know that you
know they're using the secrecy for a bit
of business in the local community but
it's like more sharing work I said all
that stuff yeah absolutely and then you
come out still in the in the in the in
the hidden and then you meet what I call
the cusp organizations this is where the
Bilderberg Group are the Council on
Foreign Relations in America that's
driven American foreign policy since
1921 in so many ways the trilateral
commission another American organization
which is similar then you've got the
Club of Rome which was created in 1968
to specifically exploit environmental
concerns to justify the transformation
of society are we talking about climate
yeah that that that's one of the one of
the the the sources of this stuff came
out of yeah and and I said just as a
quick aside I said years ago
a long time ago that the human caused
climate change was a hoax
and people said to me well why would
they hoax it and I said because they're
going to use it as an excuse problem
reaction solution in this case no
problem reaction solution to justify the
control of the fine detail of people's
lives with centralized control attacks
and so you're - yes yeah by by dictating
the fine detail of what you can and
cannot do in your life based on we must
save the world now out in America now
there's a thing called the green new
deal and you've got the the extension
rebellion organization in this country
what they are demanding is what I said
they would demand as a solution to the I
say manufactured problem anyway that
that's another story
and so these cusp organizations are
there to take the agenda for the world
from the spider through the secret
societies and these cusp organizations
gather together politicians the bank
bankers intelligence people journalists
corporations all these people
and they basically are the conduit and
there are many others of them as well to
take the spider agenda and to play it
out into the public arena so then you
come through the cusp organizations and
you hit the mainstream arena you have
governments you have government agencies
you are banking systems you have the big
farmer you have big biotech Big Oil all
these things you have Silicon Valley and
in the arena of the scene everything
seems to be happening randomly people
are making decisions and this is where
you see the pixels and then you see the
patterns and you see the picture so
basically in the world of the scene
everything seems random and unconnected
but if you go to the spider level the
Silicon Valley corporations of Facebook
and Google and YouTube and all these
people are Amazon the banking system the
big pharma cartel governments big
biotech Big Oil they're all controlled
by the same force and they're all
working to the same end and because of
the fierce compartmentalization of
knowledge what the intelligence
community called the need-to-know
technique people only letting people
need to know what they need to know to
make their contribution but not see how
it all fits together a very very few
people can drive this this web and
coming back to the subject that you you
raised what I started to see very early
on is that in this network of people in
the upper echelon so what have become
known as the the 1% there was a very
common theme of pedophilia
to a vastly greater ratio than you get
in the general population of this more
than people think in the general
population and also Satanism literally
humans sacrificing animals sacrificing
Satanism and you can chart these these
these these bloodlines if you like back
into ancient history and you can see
that all they're doing is doing things
in secret that once upon a time they
were doing in the open before it became
unacceptable ancient ritual yeah all
that stuff it's it's really unbelievably
bizarre but then these people are when
you're one of the first people who sort
of point the finger towards Jimmy Savile
well um I tell you another story call we
could talk forever can we
I usually might I was um I was invited
to the House of Lords some years ago
back in the 90s as before
no no afterwards but it was only a very
small group I mean you know most of the
people in the House of Lords would say
what's that nuts at doing here but it
was little group but this was this was
before the conspiracy side of the right
you know it started to start it had
started yeah or I've served you it had
started or he's probably talking about
96 97 97 public and anyway there's a
person there
it wasn't from the house of law to just
another person had been invited and she
started saying some very interesting
things about Princess Diana and her you
know well murder and I saw Bob stop me
I'm all ears and I'm I mean there Arthur
I'm in there afterwards so I said I'm
sort of how did you know that and she
said well um I'm a close friend of a
close friend of who was a close friend
of Diana and she was she was a close
friend of Diana for nine years and she
was acknowledged as such by the
mainstream media by the way and she said
I I think my friend will talk to you so
about a week later I meeting the two of
them off they are a white fairy and we I
sat down I still got the tape at home
you know those old old tapes those
changes and I've still got the interview
on that at home and she told me a lot of
things a lot of very weird things about
the royal family which have all turned
out to be true from other sources but
one of the things she told me was that
Jimmy Savile was pedophile and that he
was operating in the inner circle of the
British royal family and that Diana
thought he was sleazy and horrible he
was also even used as a go-between I
mean this is this aging disc jockey as a
go-between in the marriage
problems between Diana and Charles
because because he was a very close
friend of Charles and this is the story
Sabol was introduced into the British
royal family by his own words this part
by Lord Mountbatten course a a big
member of the royal family in the 1960s
and he stayed in the inner circle of the
British royal family the inner bosom all
the way through almost to the end of his
life our news friends with Thatcher as
well as me yes he was and and that that
that will present in a minute and all
and so I've been writing for years that
Lord Mountbatten was a pedophile and I
don't whether you noticed that in the
last like three weeks a month a books
come out quoting documents from the FBI
in which they were also naming sources
for Mountbatten being a pedophile
obviously related to the royal family
or was that very closely related you see
that the royal family of Britain is
German royal family it's really the
house of saxe-coburg-gotha and they
changed the name to win so during the
First World War cuz their family in
Germany we are was at war with us right
and there was another German family
royal family connected to to them called
Battenberg and they during the First
World War at the same time had a good
cake they they changed their name to
Mountbatten sense Lord Mountbatten
anyway it was it was an absolutely
horrible piece of work was Mountbatten
but let's look let's look at the the
themes here a known pedophile Lord
Mountbatten has introduced into the
inner core of the British royal family a
historic pedophile
of historic proportions and he stayed in
the inner circle all the way through
almost to his death he's used as an
inter intermediary between Charles and
Diana when their marriage was in trouble
and
it's known the police knew about Savile
they interviewed him they knew what he
was doing but for some reason he wasn't
nailed and he wasn't nailed because
what's not come out in the media is that
he was a procurer of children for the
rich and famous and therefore his back
was watched now because if he goes down
they all yeah and also he was apparently
very good at procuring children he buddy
had children's hospitals on top didn't
you because he wasn't the owner of them
one of the other things I pointed out at
the time of his death before it all the
whole thing came out was that he was a
necrophiliac he which is ology like
having sex sex with dead bodies people
who thought I was a bit weird you know I
mean we're talking suddenly you almost
seem like I'm sorta missionary sex yeah
but this is the thing this is the thing
that's why Jimmy Savile famously
volunteered as a porter at Leeds General
Hospital it gave him access to the
frickin mortuary well these are the
people this this is the mentality we're
talking about right so the police knew
about that well all the way through
these years so special branch of the
police the elite section that connects
into royalty protection knew about Sabol
British intelligence knew about Sabol
clearly and you cannot COFF out-of-tune
near the British royal family without
these authorities know all about it yeah
and they have they allowed a historic
scale pedophile and a procurer of
children for the rich and famous to be
in the inner sanctum of the British
royal family all that time and then when
it came out Charles said they never told
me I'll do leave off and wait with one
of your mates is into some dodgy [__]
you'll know about Tommy with that Baba's
yeah
yeah so comes back to what you've just
brought up earlier Epstein wait what
isn't here procurer yes he's a procure
of children for the rich in Germany Mori
isn't he was the Jimmy saw was the Jimmy
Savile of America and you know after
Jimmy Savile his career ended as a disc
jockey and Jim will fix in all that
stuff he was just a pedophile then he
still had a stream of houses big cars a
Bentley with no obvious means of income
what his income came from what he was
doing and Epstein I mean the the the
millions that he had it there's no real
explanation about where it came from
because it's the same story you you know
when you're doing that you get the money
to do it and so what
when Epstein was connected to Prince
Andrew in the British royal family here
you've just lost your perkier I step in
it's it's all the same I've lost
benighted as well you know when I
started talking about this they ain't
got to give me an item and I'm
devastated there's one thing about
Epstein
apparently Prince Andrew was
photographed in his house that's right
and there's a white banister yeah and if
I was sure that word went to the house
with the camera crew and has recently
got footage should decide the house I
got the white banner studies like look
there it is he's bang to rights Prince
Andrew and so you had do you know with
some people there's all Annika Lee
there's always something a bit Prince
Andrew is a bit one of them this I know
it's not quite right not many members of
the royal family where I go they look
spot-on know who often look at them and
go no good look in person to be fair
that was what's confused me Markel she
was fantastic in suits she's sort of
ruined it since she got you know he's
one of the few I'm like yeah believer
he's alright
yeah I've I've said a lot about the
British royal family over the years I've
gathered a lot of information about them
and I tell you what if a fraction of it
was seen by the mass of the British
people there'd be a revolution by that
by the morning
and then we out because they are
absolutely despicable Jeremy Corbyn what
what Epstein was running was a blackmail
operation for Mossad the Israeli
intelligence in league with the CIA what
they do this is why some of these people
that these young young girls was who
said they were abused and trafficked by
Epstein I've spoken openly about the
fact that there were cameras all or
nothing oh yeah there were cameras all
over these things an audio and and I've
been writing about this for like 25
years the way that they bring in
politicians and other people they need
to control so they make the decisions
that suit this agenda and they get them
they get them compromised with things
like sex with children they make sure
that the tapes are there see one of the
place one of the sources of children
abused by Lord Mountbatten
and Ted Heath by the way former prime
minister Wow I named him as a pedophile
and a Satanist in a book called the
biggest secret seven years before he
died he was still an MP the passage was
read to him the week of publication uh
and he did nothing and it took 17 years
after that for Bookshare police to start
an investigation into what Heath was
what was was up to but the place that
Heath and Mountbatten got children from
was a children's home in a child care
home in Belfast called Cohn Cora and it
came out that what British intelligence
were doing was providing children at
King Cora to foreign dignitaries and
people like that and anyone else they
wanted to compromise and they were
filming it and then once they've got the
fill okay um what's your policy gonna be
what the policy is whatever you tell me
it's gonna be that's how it works so you
have here British intelligence not just
here in many other areas as the CIA do
it as well Moss said do it all the time
literally setting out to compromise
people so that they will make decisions
that suit their agenda which fits
absolutely with a what Epstein was doing
but also the fact that British
intelligence knew about Jimmy Savile in
the inner circle of the British royal
family and did nothing about it
you know this lady Gill a Maxwell hmm
her father was a Mossad agent Bob
Maxwell I I interviewed Bob Maxwell once
he owned Oxford United Football Club at
one time and I was working on a program
with the BBC at the time called sports
night long gone bless it
and I did this documentary on Oxford
went and him he was a horrible horrible
man and I didn't even know then the
scale of it but he was a horrible man he
waited he's talked to his staff at the
Daily Mirror I interviewed him at the
Daily Mirror which here which he owned
he was a Mossad agent for a long time
person I quote in the book called Viktor
Ostrovsky and he was a longtime Mossad
agent a case officer with Mossad and in
1990 he wrote a book exposing it all and
he wrote a second one and in the second
one he describes the activities of Bob
Maxwell who was doing things for for
Mossad while posing as a businessman and
how when Maxwell's Empire started to
break down you know you went bankrupt
and he pinched the pension funds you
member of the mirror employees Mossad
decided that he was he was now a
liability and they killed him
Ostrosky 'm describes how they did it
was like on a boat a boat called the
lady Ghislaine and they they did it with
divers because that what you think up an
Epstein that they kill him off where I'm
going with this is the irony at the
irony of course after the eighties
they've killed him and then they give
him a hero's funeral on the Mount of
Olives in Jerusalem acts well but his
daughter ghilane Maxwell the daughter of
a Mossad agent is
- Epstein big-time she was a procurer
for him it is alleged with enormous
evidence and he was running a mas ad
blackmail operation so you can see how
it all kind of fits together and what
happened with Epstein because what they
do is this as with Sabol when you serve
them they'll watch your back but there
is a limit so with Epstein when it first
came out he was given this
extraordinarily tame plea deal for
something that would have you know
pedophilia would have put him in jail
for a very long time he basically he had
nothing that you know he was given a
sentence on a plea deal which allowed
him to leave the prison during the
working day and right but and good on
him these former young girls now women
wouldn't let it go and more and more
stuff came out and and he was really and
then the plea deal came out people
started realizing they were outraged so
so he's now becoming like Maxwell became
he's becoming a liability because if
this guy's going in court but what the
hell's gonna come out or we all could go
down that'll yes so so what do we have
we have a situation where he's he's put
in to a cell in this very major secure
operation in Manhattan and then it's
claimed that he's tried to commit
suicide he told his lawyers someone
tried to kill him and so because they
said it was suicide they put him on
suicide watch so there's no way he's
gonna have the opportunity to kill
himself on suicide watch
so what they then did is they remove the
suicide watch and they took away the
prisoner in the cell with him so does
that that is the opposite of what they
usually do absolutely this is not really
nice I'd watch it's a suicide
the medius and then and then you've got
the prison guards who's supposed to be
looking after him who fell asleep on his
something give him a Mickey Finn or
something but they fell asleep that if
that's the story but you still got a
chance cuz these two cameras pointing
down the corridor and anyone going in
and out you see them all they don't work
just like the same camera ops as patnik
on hell yeah in 11 yes someone lost the
turns and and Princess Diana I in a book
called the biggest secret I go into the
Diana we need to do diana next you've
got a touch on the and between the Ritz
Hotel and the Pont Alma tunnel of 17
traffic cameras including one I got a
picture of it looking down at the
entrance to the tunnel as that you go in
17 cameras none of them working in the
period when she was when she was
imagining hits to her death none of them
working and there was you know one of
these people though sorry but both the
Epstein thing though you're you're
leaning towards he was murdered then
yeah definitely murdered but there is
another possibility but it you know I
only throw hours as a possibility and
some people are saying well just hold on
a second with whether he murdered he was
murdered maybe they got him away somehow
right because they do do that yeah you
know I would recently come into the
hands of his black book yeah yeah yeah
yeah and he stopped ringing everyone
like we're talking like Bill Clinton Liz
Hurley like every celebrity so in that
black book what exactly is that flashes
phone numbers there's no proof of
anything that's going on but you're
getting the scale of the level of
celebrity in the level of like info high
and what Sean said was it's the ones you
don't know that other most frightening
of all of these exactly and the other
thing is a number of those names in that
pot there's multiple friggin numbers oh
yeah yeah yeah and you're talking about
people from all over the globe who are
princes and yeah you're Sultan's know
why not fits perfectly with what I've
been writing over the years that
literally I would go as far as to say
this the cement
that holds this web together is
pedophilia and Satanism this guy Epstein
was like goober eats for Peters basic
like he delivered it was crazy who are
the good guys it's gotta be good guys
because what I'm always struck by is if
these people want to silence anyone it
would be you why why let you continue
well with me the way my life has gone in
the last thirty years in many ways has
been absolutely perfect because of
course the enormous ridicule that I got
right four years in the early nineteen
nineties one done and onwards meant that
when I started coming out with his stuff
I wouldn't have been seen as a threat
right because everyone thinks he's mad
anyway and in fact if he's saying this
he's gone on people will actually not
believe it because he's saying it there
then came a period in nine eleven was
part of it when there was a big shift
yeah and people started to say well hold
on a minute what this blokes saying is
making sense it is certainly making
sense of what's going on and look at all
the things he said in these earlier
books that are happening but at that
time I'm up and running because you
became out there you became a bit of a
lightning rod and imagine for these kind
of things because you're saying it other
people who have also been doubted or
ridiculed they're going well I can go
and tell him things yeah that's that's
what happens because some of the things
that are going all out of the things
that are going on are so absolutely
fantastic I mean the the greatest
defense that this conspiracy has and
people say about people like me you see
conspiracies everywhere I don't yeah I
see one conspiracy right is a multiple
faces when you worm when you look at the
way that this sum this whole conspiracy
works it's it's and you're willing to
put it out there people who generally
will not get a hearing anywhere hmm no
they'll get a hearing from me and so
you're absolutely right you become a
lightning rod once you start putting it
out there people then say well this
guy's a vehicle
I know getting out there so you do get
approached like that but of course you
have to be very very careful and I have
a technique I've used which is served me
very well I call it the back burner
technique when people have told me
absolutely fantastic things I mean like
what you like but you mean terrible
things yeah and also far out things what
I I don't
a dismiss them unless through previous
research I know them to be not true and
B I don't accept to me though I put them
on the back burner and our way and I see
what other information comes in relation
to that subject and then there comes a
point so what I did with the pedophiles
I got so much information about this
stuff in in the 90s and eventually there
comes a point where you cross a line
you've got so many stories telling you
the same things about the same people
from so many different sources who were
not connected that you cross the line
and at that point you say I'm going with
this hmm
and if what it's turned out to be true
have you ever sort of imagined even come
into a few scenarios where you sort of
fear for your life or sort of ever been
worried no never
you've never thought I am coming out
with so much like you say fantastical
stuff that I'm you know the hotel I go
to tonight right you know no never
and people say you have a bodyguard you
know you know what a body doesn't you
know the body God is a witness it is an
external acceptance right that other
people have power over you I don't
accept that that's why I don't have a
body god I hate it well you don't bloody
need one yes I see you although if you
if you do need one yeah maybe letting
abrasive yeah yeah but I know what
you're saying though you don't want to
give them that power no I won't give
them the power they can't they cannot
stop me you see we are consciousness and
and and and we can tap into expanded and
expanded levels of consciousness that
give us enormous power to doing enormous
things which gives us enormous levels of
potential to make things
so how have you have you do you meditate
boss and I just just live my life
knowing that I have more power than they
do and you see if you look at how this
cabal works it works on intimidation and
it works
timid Aish is another word of saying
getting people to give a [__] right
it's about persuading the public to give
their power away to them they give their
power away and different levels to
politicians you know do something
instead of saying what am I going to do
about it it's what they gonna do about
it and and then they give their power
away through consequences right like
what will this cabal do to me if I come
out with this stuff I'll be so many
people have given me information
some of them well-known people and
they've said I'll keep it I'll give you
it mate but for God's sake don't say
you've got it for me it's this fear i
write a norma cement about the nature of
reality and the nature of life and the
nature of the eye and we this body is
just a vehicle for a very transitory
experience in a tiny band of frequencies
that we call the world and and and when
it's over the true i consciousness
awareness will leave and explore forever
forever somewhere else so when you you
you you see life through that infinite
on that infinite level then this little
trance retreats perience we call a human
life it takes on a very different a very
different perception for instance well
they might kill you okay so I'm not
gonna do what I know to be right because
they might kill me okay what does that
mean I am gonna leave this body at some
point anyway so I'm not gonna do what I
know to be right out of fear of leaving
the body just a bit earlier than up
intone Hollywood yeah I think I could
handle that I've always liked that about
you that you sort of viewed life in
terms of perspective and time that we're
here
the way I do that's the one thing I've
always identified with you and I sort of
wondered if you'd ever maybe lost
someone earlier in life that taught you
that if this is all temporary
no it's I've always rejected religion
and I've always rejected this world is
all there is life's a [__] and then you
die science but until I had my awakening
shall we say in 1990 I never really
explored you know the alternative and
then a series of incredible paranormal
experiences over a long period of time
put this information in front of me and
I tell I tell you a quick story when I
was writing Alice in Wonderland the
World Trade Center disaster I was saying
to people you know if I'm going to get
to another level of understanding of
what the hell's going on I'm gonna have
to get out there and see this reality
and enough from another perspective not
in some dream where you wake up and you
think you know was that real or was it a
dream but actually where I consciously
see it but at the same time I got an
invite to go to Brazil the Brazilian
rainforest 2003 this is and and partake
of something called ayahuasca as well as
talking to a to a group it was over a
week and I could have taken this
ayahuasca four times it's ring for its
plan to took it twice I had the most
extraordinary experience some people
have bad experiences by the way but
particularly on the second night
what is it taste like licorice and and
you take it and then it takes about an
hour to kick in and what happens is when
you close your eyes you're in another
reality but when you open your eyes
you're back in this one the thing is
though that your eyes don't want to stay
open so they keep shutting and what
happened in in that five hours is as it
kicked in this female voice as loud as
mine is now started to explain the
nature of physical reality and how it's
all an illusion a holographic illusory
physical illusion
and how it's just basically an
experience and we are consciousness and
the consciousness is eternal it's
indestructible it just goes on anyway
and loads and loads and loads of other
things and I came back to Britain and I
started researching mainstream science
and quantum physics and I found that
science had sussed what this voice had
told me but because they operate in
disciplines instead of the whole there
were all in different parts and when you
put the parts together the evidence is
already there in this world that this is
a an illusion and so it transformed my
voice transformed everything because you
know most people and that the system
does this on purpose I've written at
length about this how the system does it
from cradle to grave from from cradle to
grave a human life is a download of
perceptional programming that's what it
is the education system is simply
downloading to the the young population
a perception of reality and they test
you if you've accepted that level of
reality nature of reality by exams and
then the media is pounding out the same
version of reality mainstream science
and mainstream medicine is panning out
the same reality and as long as you keep
paying your taxes and tournament yeah
and it's it's it's based on what I call
the postage stamp consensus this is a
narrow band of information a sense of
the possible what is known as the normal
and if you stay on the normal then
you're normal
you're credible you are anyone that
steps off the postage stamp wanting to
explore other areas well they're the mad
people and the weird people and ridicule
are dangerous and all that stuff and
it's just kind of a person Mia I stepped
off the postage stamp in 1990-91 and I'm
still running you know away from it like
and you start to to to to to realize
that what
system gasps it doesn't want us to
understand the true nature of the I
doesn't because I've taught my own
experience once you know the true nature
of the I what I am is consciousness or
what I am is awareness forget the body
forget form I am a state of being aware
and I can choose to be that aware I'm
just little me I have no power what can
I do or we can choose to be as aware as
we want to be that what the system wants
us to do is to self identify with the
body it once it wants us to self
identify the I with my name my race my
sex and sexuality and all these label
attachment I yes these there wants to be
a touched on a little thing these labels
they're labels and these labels that
people self-identify with when you say
who are you they'll reel off their
labels of this world labels then they
that they are not who we are they are
what we are experiencing and what's
experiencing those lives those
situations those labels is the true I
consciousness now if you self-identify
with the labels and by the way of course
the labels and it's systemic are getting
sub divided and subdivided and
subdivided I mean how long is that
bloody Lister letters gonna get where
people have to are so obsessed with
their self-identity they have to they
have to list labels that that describe
their self-identity and the mind you
apply they blow it in there but
Instagram by this point I quoted in one
of the books a identity list of letters
that used by an American University you
know of self identities it goes on for
freaking ever so when you self-identify
with your label as opposed to that being
your experience your sense of self
impossible
contract to that label I call them I am
ours I am our man I am our woman I am
our this race or that race but when you
self-identify with being the
consciousness that's having the
experience the consciousness that moves
on what we call death then your sense of
self your sense of power your sense of
potential absolutely explodes and life
becomes much more of an adventure you
chill more because you know it's just a
temporary experience on on the road of
forever whereas you know if you
self-identify with the labels it's like
a bloody race I got a got a got a got a
got a because I go through serious that
it's the threescore years and ten in it
do you not whether you remember this
advert I obviously wasn't a good advert
but because I can't remember what it was
for but but it was a brilliant concept
it starts with this baby being born this
end-of-the that the screen and then it
flies through the air like a missile and
as it's moving it's getting older and
older and older and older and older and
then slams into a grave at the other end
and that's basically what a human life
is like in many ways the idea I mean the
number of times you meet people and
they're in retirement and and they look
back at their career god oh god oh god a
strive strive strive and they go at that
point they're coming to the end of their
life is it all about why did I do that
what was the point
the trick is seeing that before you do
it and it doesn't mean you just you know
smoke weed and play the sitar or that is
that is very funny yeah I thought before
you love you guys that up instead it
opens up a great visceral possibility
and and you start to realise this and
this is how it works and when you talk
about solutions this is the area of
solutions
imagine Wi-Fi and a computer
you've got a Wi-Fi field which is
information in a radiation field and it
takes the SIRT that form the computer
locks into that field depending how it's
encoded and where the mouse takes it
it locks into this part of the field or
that part of the field or that part of
the field and depending what it locks
into it decodes that onto the screen and
people say you said to say to people
describe the Internet to me they'd say
well it's graphics and moving pictures
and words on a screen yes it is but only
on the screen that's the only place the
internet exists in that form everywhere
else it's Wi-Fi radiation fields and
electronic codes etc and the human the
human body is it's the same principle we
have what I call cosmic Wi-Fi a more
technical way of describing it is the
quantum field of possibility and
probability imagine it as a Wi-Fi field
this as I've been calling it for decades
is a biological computer and what if you
at this Wi-Fi field it's information in
wave form now look look how the five
senses work the five senses of the ears
are classic with sound waves it takes
waveform information it turns it into
electrical information it communicates
it to the brain and the brain decodes it
into holographic digital information and
that holographic digital information is
this world we experience as outside of
us it's not outside of us it's in here
just as the Internet is inside the
computer we just observe it on the
screen so what you do when you're on a
computer you are making decisions
through your perceptions of where you
want to go on the Internet so you are by
where you go dictating what goes on the
screen is next up recessions work
exactly the same everything that we
think every thought every emotional
state is broadcast as
frequency everything's a frequency hate
is a certain frequency love is a very
different frequency depression is one
frequency and you know it when people
are in states of depression and anxiety
what do they say I feel so heavy today
why because those frequencies are very
low and slow and they're energetic field
starts to vibrate very slowly and it
enters a a much more dense state and we
feel it as of feeling heavy today and
then one day we wake up we've got we
full of joy and what do people say I
feel so light today because the the
positive emotions and thoughts of of
love of joy are very fast frequencies
and therefore you feel light you
literally do so our perceptions whether
we believe ourselves to be little me or
infinite me they are vastly different
frequencies bands of frequency so if
you're in a perception of I'm little me
I have no power then you are
broadcasting operating on a very narrow
band and low frequency band of
perception and that is interacting with
the cosmic Wi-Fi the quantum field of
possibility and probability within that
band and you will create a feedback loop
in which you will experience your own
perceptions little me perception becomes
little me life experience like those
people who are constantly be mourning
bad luck yeah and it's like exactly
[__] wonderment yeah it's all you
[__] talk about yeah I things were
going or going alright but you watch
something you watch something happen
yeah okay really there you go there's
the feedback loop and so when you when
you see yourself in in very limited
label terms and in especially in
powerless terms you are creating a
self-fulfilling prophecy through this
feedback loop with your perceptions are
interacting with possibility and
creating an experience of your
perceptions when do you break out of
that and use you urea self-identified
the I to be the consciousness that's
having the experience the very fact that
you have expanded your self identity
from Ethel on the checkout to infinite
consciousness having an experience as
Ethel on the checkout then that very
expansion of self identity creates an
expansion of consciousness and now you
are interacting with the quantum field
of possibility and probability cosmic
Wi-Fi as I call it in a much more
expanded way and on a much much much
more high frequency and that means that
you are able to tap in to a vastly
greater scale of possibility and
probability and your life starts to
change and I know this from my own life
and I know it from talking to other
people who've been through this process
and you know it's not sitting
cross-legged on a mountain you know just
saying mantras it's not going on quests
and fasts it's simply saying I am NOT my
labels
I am the consciousness having them
infinite awareness having them they are
my experiences they're not me and and
what happens is people notice I did in
1990-91 big time suddenly amazing
synchronicity starts to happen like what
we will call bits of luck that things
just drop in your lap and things just
start to happen and you you'll meet
someone in a situation where you'd say
what's the statistical chances of this
and any and it becomes an life becomes
an adventure because amazing things are
happening to you everything's just
dropping in your lap whereas people
think they have to strive for that they
chill out and realize that actually
we're picking out of the cosmic Internet
through our perceptions our experiences
we'd realize that instead of having to
strive for them we just attract them and
so as people in little Mima
go through lives and there's no
synchronicity and life's kind of
everything's the same of course
everything's the same because you're
you're accessing such a tiny band of
possibility and probability your life's
going to reflect that but suddenly it
opens and over the last 30 years I could
not have written that book I could not
written any of the book especially the
number I've written and I could not have
done the things that I've done if I only
worked on the five senses sitting down
in a room trying to work it out this
information has come to me in the most
amazingly synchronistic way it's like
some force has been handed me puzzle
pieces in a jigsaw puzzle in an order
that makes it easiest to see where the
pieces go and the more pieces you put in
a course the more you see the picture
the quickly I put the pieces in and
that's how it works and and this is not
you know this guy Ike sitting
cross-legged on the mountain going you
know like this anybody can do this
anybody can do this it's just a choice
people watching this now you can
transform your life by transforming your
self-identity and living it because one
thing that happens when you start to
expand your awareness is you realize
that what people say about you and do
about you is okie matter they'll do
something else tomorrow you know if we
when people have a goers but you know
other people that really cured me in the
street twenty thirty years ago they're
now stopping me in the street wanting to
talk seriously about this information
you know we must remember this whatever
they're saying now they'll say something
else tomorrow so don't let it affect you
and it doesn't affect you because you
start to realize hey I am I am a point
of attention within an infinite state of
consciousness or which were all points
of attention of the same consciousness
and I'm I am I am potentially if I want
to open myself to it I am all that is
has been and ever can be which is what
all possibility and all potential is
everything has been isn't ever can be a
dime
I'm concerned about some prat of a troll
in his bedroom Earling abuse at me on
the Internet
I'm infinite freakin awareness but if
you if you if you're little me
identifying with your label then that
troll can take on a real much greater
impact upon you you have to hit a
certain point though some people call it
rock bottom when you get at that point
in your head website this is the worst
thing that can ever happen to me I'm in
the worst place ever and you realize
what I'm still alive this isn't that bad
this is all like you have to actually be
put in that situation to realize how not
serious at all it's not a great line
from a song freedom's just another word
for nothing left to lose well when
you've got yeah when you when you I've
lost everything free to do anything
exactly that's that's the phrase it's so
um can set you free because we won't be
in there few only yeah well when you
when you've lost everything you've got
nothing left to lose so and if you if
you analyze people especially people
with lots of money they are imprisoned
by fear of losing it
Madonna right fear fear of losing it
because they've got something to lose
and again when you get into this self
identity of being a state of infinite
awareness just moving through reality
and this is just a temporary experience
we're having then what is there to
freaking lose you've gone on whether you
haven't is just an experience you lose
all at the end you kind of to go with
you but you gain your because once you
leave the body that this reality is such
a prison compared with what's beyond it
one thing we brought up earlier was the
Princess Diana death you alluded to the
fact that you thought she was murdered
yeah I mean why do you think that well
she knew she knew literally and
symbolically where the bodies were
buried for a start
what bodies well when I went out what I
mean is she knew the big secrets of the
British royal family
I mean you know I mean she the lady who
was a friend of hers close friend of
hers for nine years and like I said
knowledge is such in the media was was
telling me the horrific way she was
treated by the British royal family and
one of the people that Diana focused on
in terms of the most evil was actually
the Queen Mother and I know that from
other sources as well and she was her
image if you remember was that as the
nation's grandmother I didn't think she
looked friendly no she'd know I
absolutely agree with you but but but
that that was that was her room
that was her image when it the nation's
grandmother and they they brought her in
because they wanted her jeans not a
Levi's they wanted her jeans
yeah good-looking woman and she was from
here and why she who Diana no oh sorry
if we met the Queen Mother I was like oh
she was a right fit okay yeah oh yeah I
should have fantasies about the Queen
Mother yeah yeah different fantasies so
Diana was of high standing class wasn't
she yeah well she was some of the
Spencer I'm healing the Spencer family
and they wanted her genes there's other
reasons why they wanted the genes but
that's a very deep story goat will be
keep us here for another four hours but
and so if you notice that once they got
the genes that's she got back to Camila
when she talked to yeah exactly that
when she couldn't uh before her awesome
yeah all the way through yeah I'm
shamelessly insulted in a way she was
only she was only mean she was nowhere
near us but she was only brought in to
as part of the gene pool because it's
like I've written at length in the books
these people are they interbreed with
each other because there's a certain
genetic structure they want to protect
and if you breed outside of that network
if you like then it gets diluted very
quickly Harris this is where
interbreeding is brawly's breeding comes
from do you think Harry was not of well
you look very much like the other family
you it any the one who knows
obvious shocking I will only say that
but so many ways it doesn't matter who
Harry goes with after that no I mean the
the the the key bloodline is the the
major blood like William exact and
what-have-you that's the main Harry can
do what he wants
crack on without fee across race woman
yeah but I may put it yeah it is what
this interbreeding is phenomenal and you
know I it goes so far this network which
is for rhesus I explained in the books
and it's very explainable is obsessed
with its genetics and holding this
genetics because I've just described
when we were talking about reality the
the body decodes this reality and also
allows us to interact with other
realities DNA for instance is a receiver
transmitter this an antenna this is well
known now the cutting edge of science if
you have a certain genetics then your
receiver transmitter system operates
differently in their terms they can
access a wider band of frequency than
humans in general can in other words
they've got a much greater scale of of
what they can see why do you think that
is what's because of the way that their
their particular genetic line inter
interaction with reality differently to
the main human race so regular chores
don't hover imagine imagine imagine
you've got a band of frequency which we
have it's called visible light beyond
which we can't see just as just as just
a quick aside you know just to give you
an idea of how illusory this this world
is according to mainstream science the
electromagnetic spectrum is naught point
naught naught 5% of what exists in the
universe and visible light which is the
only frequency band that we can see is a
smear of the naught point naught naught
5% we're basically blind everything
beyond it we can't see not because it's
not there but because we can't we are
tuned to a certain channel like a
television channel and we can't see
beyond it
the these this genetic structure
interacts with reality in a different
way which allows them to see further
further into the field so so that makes
them far more aware now that's one of
the reasons now how have you have you
come upon this information thirty years
of full-time research I've talked to
endless people on both sides of the
Atlantic and around the world because
there's a lot of what you've said today
if I was 911 and and I mean I agree with
a lot of what you said about 911 but for
this I think there's a lot of people at
home gonna be like yeah how well y-yeah
you know what I mean but the point is if
if if I can see and understand more
about reality and how it works than you
can I can manipulate to my heart's
content
you know they that's why they're at the
top we you say are far more aware of
reality than we are
well most people are anyway does that
mean they think they're above absolute
ly they look on the rest of humanity
like like like like cattle like I guess
we kind of offer them again Jacob Riis
Marc yeah but so what why else would you
sit on a golden throne while everyone
else's yeah but then why would you go to
so many garden parties like a she it
goes to endless garden parties you think
there's somewhere the higher reality you
go [__] the God yeah yeah yeah this but
you know I mean it would be always
season but this reality is not a higher
reality it's a more expanded reality in
the sense of they're aware of more but
it doesn't mean it's a higher reality if
they were in a higher reality of a more
expanded reality in terms of
consciousness they wouldn't do what they
do can I also see they operate in a very
low band of frequency and they are
obsessed with the the dark occult this
is why they're in to Satan ISM and stuff
like this
because I mean they believe in God if
they believe in Satan well they don't
really believe in in in Satan they have
their their gods plural which they
worship and if you go back to the
ancient world to your Egypt's and your
babylons and you look at their belief
systems in the gods they worship they're
the same gods that these people
worshipped
I mean some of the most famous people on
earth British royal family I mean you
see them all the time go into church
right they're not Christians and the the
Christian religion in fact is is a
publicly acceptable version of the
Babylonian satanic Yashin it's that
that's what happened when just
repackaged in um in Babylon they
worshiped a trinity of Nimrod the Father
God and Tomas the thirteen born son and
Queen Semiramis the Virgin Mother and
when they just a an add to that in the
Babylonian belief system when Nimrod
died he became the Sun God Baal and
impregnated Queen Semiramis with the
Rays of the Sun which allowed her to
give a virgin birth to Thomas the
Babylonian version of Jesus so when the
Babylonians moved in on Rome's out of
that came Christianity they it was the
same religion basically and instead of
Nimrod the Father God it was Almighty
father God yeah you had Jesus and Sarah
Thomas Marin on the third part of the
Trinity in Christianity you have the
Holy Ghost or the Holy Spirit which is
symbolized as a dove and in Babylon
Semiramis was symbolized as a dove no
and what they did in the Christian
religion was take all the attributes
that the Babylonians gave to Queen
Semiramis which was Queen of Heaven
virgin mother and they gave them to a
character they called mother Mary and
and so the Christian religion is a
publicly acceptable version of the
Babylonian religion so you know these
people go to church to Christian
churches then they're not really they're
not Christians at all they are they are
occultists the Rothschilds have very
very skilled occultists and and the
royal family is always all occult and
and and like I said earlier you know
what is happening in the world
compared with what people think is
happening because of this perceptional
programming from cradle to grave is so
dramatically different that that's its
biggest defense mechanism because you
say to people this is what's happening
even if you produce the evidence they'll
go now
that's loud mate and I'd say this to
people please don't confuse what is
happening with your perception of what
could be happening because what you
believe is possible is not the limits of
possibility it's only what you believe
is possible and what's possible is way
beyond what gone become up the diana is
there any main reasons you feel like she
was murdered
well I wonder one of the reasons was
well the key reasons was she was a big
problem
she'd provided the genes and and she
realized that I mean she took when she
talked to this writer Andrew Morton for
the book which was basically quoting her
and what I was told by her friend of
nine years was the same start of
basically plus some other stuff that
they'd got her genes but she was a
feisty character and she she wanted some
revenge here because she was absolutely
second by the way she'd been treated
she'd realized that she was the Windsors
brood mare I think a one phrase that the
the friend used and I was growing in
popularity
yeah great Chanti she was annoying for
the royal family it seemed as that
they'd always be in the thing and then
all of a sudden she was the darling the
media like doing all this charity work
everyone loved her yeah exactly and she
was becoming bigger than the royal
family and and I go back to it she knew
their secrets and if you remember the
interview on panorama she obviously
showed with that interview that she was
quite willing to reveal him you know
there are three of us in this
relationship
she wants it done she what she wanted
some well we call it revenge I don't
know she wanted some some some payback
for the way they treated her and so she
was a big problem
and and they got rid of her there was a
doggy doggy photo fired yeah those
rumors ever been pregnant as well the
one thing I don't buy that the one thing
I've found to be like the biggest red
flag was after the accident how long it
took them to get her into a hospital
apparently there was this whole yeah
time period wave when accounted for four
hours and then they didn't they embalm
her body as well as something like oh
yeah I mean they they killed her and
then cover the evidence we were just
talking about I mean you know you get a
constant repeating of the same
techniques as 9/11 was with so much had
happened to 9/11 was just what they did
with the Oklahoma bombing in 1995
including the FBI turning up and taking
all the cameras that showed what
actually happened oh we never seen him
ever since the usual techniques but with
them with Diana I mean I went to Paris
twice I wrote about this at length in
the biggest secret which came out in
1998 and all the stuff from her friend
is in the pork and some of it is
seriously far out but has turned out to
be true anyway and I walk the route and
where they were supposed to go be going
back to was Dodie's flat which is on the
Chantilly say here near the Arc de
Triomphe lovely oh and here's the Ritz
Hotel and what you did because I walk
the route like I say twice you come down
from the Ritz Hotel you go round the
plaster la Concorde a little bit you
turn right and you go up the shots ELISA
what her car did that night was come all
the way round missed the turn to the
Sean's ELISA went round and went onto
this road very fast road which went
through the Pont Dalma tunnel was a very
short tunnel really and so he's going at
speed and he's going further and further
away from where they're supposed to be
going I mean nothing makes sense that
night at all and like you said like you
say and I go into this in the biggest
secret the time it took for them to get
there was ridiculous for something if
what they say is true
collapse chest and internal bleeding
needed urgent for in surgery but she
never got it and and it was it was a it
was a it was a blatant bloody murder and
of course again I mean just just think
Epstein however when people are bout to
speak out or have yes we go however
however the means they've got rid of
Epstein they've got rid of Epstein who
was a major bridge a problem for
exposing the wider story and they got
rid of of her who was in danger of
exposing the wider story another thing I
wonder mentioned it earlier but you know
these people that they they go on this
police frequencies and listen to the
police you know interactions and stuff
well that night not only did 17 traffic
cameras not work which is happens all
the time cameras are there to keep
surveillance on the population but
they're a problem when the Cabal does
it's its operations when there's cameras
around that's why the cameras are never
working or they are confiscated like
with 911 and so when the Brazilian
electricity electrician was being shot
seven times in the head after the 7/7
bombings by the police while they held
him down and the guy who did it got
promoted the the cameras weren't working
see so this is it's quite it's it's it's
common theme but at the same time they
weren't working there was one of these
kind of blokes with the tuning in to the
police frequencies and he knew nothing
was got he got home before he realized
anything had happened but he's sitting
on a on a bench near the Eiffel Tower
which is right across the river from the
Pont alma tunnel and he said the police
frequencies went down for half an hour
nothing silence and that was the period
that happened it's like a you know I've
said a few times here if you look at
dots individual happenings they look a
certain way
but you start to connect them and you
see the pattern and it's blatantly
obvious what's happened in plenty over
she was murdered when you say about the
royal family being Satanists and stuff
like that like when I hear that I don't
know about you I think of Alec Eyes Wide
Shut like you know like it so I think of
worship than the eyes why shut seems
relatively tame - I allegedly rise but
like really worse but a version of it I
imagine they're not like dudes and sex
but they're more like murdering yeah oh
no the sex thing big time yeah but the
oh yeah big time yeah because the the
sexual energy is one of these is it's a
it's a long story but part of the occult
is is sexual energy but um what is its
kind of interesting eyes wide shot
because Stanley Kubrick was trying to
tell us something you know Stanley
Kubrick's daughter is some is someone's
into this information in remember she's
into the conspiracy information about
Kubrick sorry to cut you off : there was
rumors of keurig being the secret
director behind the fake 9/11 moon
landing the moon landing yet yeah yeah I
think I think that's true yeah there's
I've got a friend in America called Jay
whiner
who's done to DVD documentaries he's
been researching said if the moon
landing was faked they would have got
this was Stanley he's been researching
Kubrick for a long time and he he points
out that what was that and he does this
was very very considerable detail what
was that film that Kubrick was involved
in a Space Odyssey to see how he felt
that that was shot in the same period of
them as the moon landings were being
orchestrated and happening and he shows
in in the shots of the moon landings
[Music]
Kubrick's
filming techniques used in a Space
Odyssey
appear on the moon landing shots he is
it's brilliantly done because the reason
they went for Kubrick was because at the
time he was cutting a wouldn't be today
of course
because they have now but he was cutting
edge in terms of special effects and
what what Jay does is he he shows you
one scenes from the the Kubrick film a
Space Odyssey and then he shows you
pictures of the moon landing it shots on
the moon and the same techniques you can
almost see the frickin background
anyways it's fascinating but Kubrick was
trying to get through wise Wide Shut
which was about mind control and this
elite occult Satanism because he was an
insider he knew at what went on to
ironic that he picked Tom Cruise yeah
why maybe it wasn't and maybe maybe I
bet there's a lot of similar oh yeah
there was a lot of symbolism and and
yeah that's another story but he he
actually selected you know you know the
the manor house what that was meant more
towers in England that was built by the
Rothschilds and it's quite obsessed with
them England in general yeah and the
upper and the elites of England
yes yeah and I'm saying but it was it
was presented in the in the movie as it
being in America yeah yeah that's what
it was and the way Kubrick worked is he
he was very very skilled in symbolism
very skilled and so if you understand it
understood the symbolism you could read
what he was actually saying when it
appeared to everyone else he was just a
movie and given the the scale that he
used symbolism there's no way that he
filmed at a house the Rothschilds bill
for that foil and also in your ending
are no easy is a huge like what does
this really mean
like yeah you're supposed to look deeper
into it after the end of the MV as well
well III spent from 1996 to about 2001
2002 deeply investigating both sides of
the Atlantic mind control mind control
techniques and how they work and there
are some absolutely classic scenes you
know you know with in in the in the film
Cruz's wife Nicole Kidman yeah she kept
having flashbacks of having sex with a
navy guy and all that stuff [__] and
they're all keep having flashbacks
that's classic mind control Kubrick
absolutely was putting it on a public
display but I don't whether you know
this that he died of course after that
very soon after that film was given to
Warner Brothers and what what you know J
whiney was saying is that when and other
people have said this as well that when
he gave them the original movie the
Warner Brothers executives were watching
it in a you know theater and and when
they walked out they they basically this
is this great director is they just they
just ignored him they just walked past
him and insisted that twenty five
minutes of the movie was cut yeah and
according to jy no because of his when
when he agreed to fake the moon landing
shots he thought well I'm gonna make
sure that I get a deal here and he got a
deal according to Jay Werner that his
movies could never be edited or censored
again so when they asked for 25 minutes
to be taken out he refused and a few
days later not long later he's dead
and they took 25 minutes out there have
never been seen and one of the reasons
in the movie there's some strange carts
because of what was taken out so when
you see what's in the movie and how far
that goes what the hell was in the 25
minutes that they wouldn't last a tea
shop it's a dark movie yeah that's real
if you notice too you had this massively
famed director it was his last movie
because he died by the time it was out I
run I think he came away eyes wide shut
yeah it came a when eyes wide shot what
they do in mind control so one of the
great mind control techniques is is use
of words for confusion where they invert
words so you have something like eyes
open now that's an obvious thing your
eyes are wide open but eyes wide shut is
an inversion in other words it's
impossible for you to have your eyes
wide shot and also what you've said
about the occult is that everything is
inverted the whole everything's you know
everything about her design yeah and the
other thing about Eyes Wide Shut is it's
um it's also a statement about much of
the human race which is people go around
with a rice white shirt in fact the
funny enough you should say this the the
opening introduction to to the trigger
is called eyes wide sharp and because
the last two chapters at the end are
called eyes wide open one-and two-and
and I talked about the Kubrick the
Kubrick film and the name of the film
Eyes Wide Shut and although you can't
have your eyes wide shot you can walk
around with your eyes open and see
nothing which is just as much as what
he's saying okay yeah that's what he's
basically saying eyes wide shut I think
what he's saying is look it this is
what's happening about John Lennon never
seen that coming do you mean the death
of John Lennon yeah yeah I mean in
general I find the Beatles are like
quite and it was John Lennon criticized
the running of the world didn't even
long before John John John Lennon was a
was a guy who had a see this is the you
know the common theme if you have a
platform and you're saying things that
they really don't want people to hear
like Kubrick maybe yeah then then you
you you you're gonna be targeted I mean
what was Diana but someone with a
massive platform willing to say things
they didn't want to hear this is the
common theme that you find with people
and Lenin was obviously challenging them
the military industrial complex and all
that stuff he pretty preached like
Thoreau gnarly yeah and he was so I was
talking about the need to love each
other now the last thing this Kivar once
is the human race to love itself and
love each other it once conflict he
wants division because when there's a
few of you and you want to control the
many you have to divide and rule the
many you can't you can't do you can't
a unified force you can only control a
divided force so what they do is they
create these fault lines and indeed all
these subdivisions of self-identity are
creating more and more fault lines now
we're having transgender activists and
very feminist activists having fights in
the street all these divisions that the
more self-identity groups you have the
more divisions potentially you have and
and so they they don't want people
coming together because you know when
you're coming from my philosophy of life
I'm saying we're all points of attention
within one infinite state of awareness
and so you are a state of awareness
having an experience there is difference
in mind but ultimately we are the same
we are the same aspects of the same
consciousness and then when you when you
come to that level hey check guys we're
all one we're all one so your own
expressions of each other but what does
that do it removes the fault lines you
get people to focus on labels and
identify with labels your fault lines
are infinite possibility of playing
people off against you especially if you
describe those labels as beneficial
labels and trick people what thinking
yeah you what you want to label call
Muslim you want to label called Jewish
you want to label called Christian you
want to label called atheist when a
label called transgender or a label cor
called gay a label called a label called
straight and you've got endless
possibilities then to play them off
against each other and everyone's
fighting each other and they don't see
that a very few people are actually
holding the strings who everybody I know
of another guy who tried ayahuasca and
met DMT is basically what the compound
is is that right at the heart of I wash
going yeah that's right people like
Jorgen have talked about it a lot Dorian
yet a bodybuilder ironically took it and
he said that walking him was that
everyone everything is one and one is
that everything is one yeah we're all
this we're all connected even though you
might see some [__] on the street
and think how can I be connected yeah
it's all you are yeah you know because
what you you've got your biological
computer yeah and it is
decoding reality via perceptions in a
particular way and you've got someone
else in a different biological computer
that is decoding reality in a different
way and so when we look at the world
everyone seems to be apart from
everything one else and and different
but when you get to the level of
consciousness beyond the body then it's
one flow of consciousness with different
points of attention in it and the other
thing about that is that you know when
we when we talk about oneness everything
being one it doesn't mean we're all the
we all have to be the body same this
oneness this infinite state of
consciousness is all possibility or
potential when people talk about being
something that you know has been is and
always will be that's impossible you
know you can't be all the ears has been
an ever can be all that's describing is
a state of all possibility and all
potential so to celebrate your
uniqueness is to celebrate that you're
part of this infinite possibility what
happens when you withdraw from that
identity into a label is you stop being
unique look at I mean you go around the
world and you get different situations
almost anyway it doesn't matter what the
culture is doesn't matter what the race
is and a certain situation will happen
and it's like pressing enter on a
computer you know how people are going
to react it creates a sameness instead
of celebrating uniqueness and what is
happening now with political correctness
don't start me and and and all this
policing of language policing of
behavior it's forcing people into a
basically a blob where everyone's the
same and there's no uniqueness left and
what that is doing is taking us out of
the state of identity with the AI which
is identifying with being all
possibility I can be anything into being
this
long and it's being policed because the
more you the more you become part of the
herd
the more you withdrawing from the true
state of AI which is consciousness you
know if you if you look at the herd
mentality it's it's just everyone
following everyone else and and that
means whoever's the frickin Shepherd
he's running the show and that's
basically how this conspiracy works two
things you got the herd of sheep or the
flock of sheep
you've got the shepherd in front with
with the stick and the Sheep of
following him and any sheep that want to
break out of that then they're sorted
out with the sheepdog which symbolizes
fear and that's how the human race is
controlled this is where fear of
consequences that's the fear of the
sheepdog basically and you know I've
stood there one day year on long time
ago and I watched this massive her sheep
coming down this hill there's a shepherd
in front and there's a sheepdog and all
these sheep were just following the one
in front and you know Eddie that got
outward sorted out by the sheepdog but I
don't remember many did and I'm sitting
there and I'm thinking I'm looking at
the human race walking past me here and
I thought well hold on a minute
what you know there's there's the
Shepherd I'm in control
I'm the authority whoa whoa and I'm the
fear and I thought what would happen if
these sheep just stopped and said hold
on a minute
I'm not following this bloke anymore I'm
out of it and the fear comes rope retro
oh you know have a nice day and they go
that way and they got that way in that
way in minutes this Shepherd authority
would have lost complete friggin control
this sheepdog would have lost control
because no-one's reacting with fear
anymore and suddenly that whole
situations changed all the sheep are
going off in in their own directions
they want to go in and this that the
control systems dead that's all we have
to do stop cooperating with our own end
slave murder problem stop policing each
other but but I remember a two-pack
interview I run it to me when I was
younger watching any course
fear is stronger than love and I didn't
have a [__] clue what he was saying
at the time but like now I've gotten
order I'm like I get I get where you are
on about now but the special people and
I've met in life are the ones who are
the other way around when love is
stronger than fear
but most people 99% of people fear rules
them shiranami
yeah but but but but but fear is not
stronger than love I mean a lot of
people it is because it's said because
the average person is a selfish [__]
prick yeah my experience anywhere and I
included me at times in that you know I
mean like we all were worried about
oneself survive like everyone's a
self-preservation mist at this point
especially resources me that kind of
plays into what David saying though
because people are sort of conditioned
to be them yeah well what I'm saying is
I feel like it's getting worse not
better
well I think it's getting better with
some people I'm seeing a big awakening
going on and with others I'm seeing it
get worse it's almost like a part of a
road getting worse Alissa parting of the
road I absolutely agree with that but I
mean this thing all died um what is it I
mean we associate love with
overwhelmingly physical attraction and
and for me the nearest thing that you
can get to real love in in in its
universal sense is friendship we've so
lost the meaning of love that we have to
put words in front of it like
unconditional to to explain what we mean
because if your love is only attraction
well that will that will probably burn
out at some point
and what happens the relationship ends
because it's it's not really based on
unconditional love friendship is this a
great line a friend is the one that
walks in the room when everyone else is
walking out where it doesn't mean you
agree with the person and you don't even
even agree with what they've done but
you're there for them because that's
because your love is without condition
and
this is the love that exists in the
greater reality the infinite reality
beyond this manipulated realm that we
experience this it's it's it's a love
that without condition and that love is
far more powerful than fear what fear
does because we we have the the body
it's actually holographic but the body
is actually an electromagnetic field
some people call it the auric field and
there are vortex points through this
field which are known in the East as
chakras meaning wheels of light their
vortex is in the field there are some
photographic techniques that can
photograph them now and and there's
seven major ones through the human
energetic field beyond this visible
light spectrum that our eyes can see and
the key the key one is right here in the
middle of the chest and it's called the
heart chakra in the east our vortex you
might call it now this is where from
ancient times the association between
the heart and love came from not the
physical heart I mean they they
symbolize it as the physical heart I
don't they understandably but it's this
when you're feeling love for someone you
don't feel it here this vortex here
relates to emotion that's why we feel
emotion in the belly that's why when we
nervous we get the shit's that it is
that that's the reason because of the
way that the fear and anxiety affects
this vortex on the gear with the gut ya
gut reaction that comes from here and so
this is is is where we feel love and
Okan my heart goes out and we feel
compassion from here this is why and in
most people the head is the arbiter of
perception and it's the arbiter of
action the head is a very very limited
state we call it the intellect people we
worship
the intellect the intellect is the
village idiot compared with this
this is innate intelligence this is
learned intelligence and when you open
your heart and what fear does is it
shuts it down you know people talk about
there are a king and all that stuff it
fear shuts it down what is a selfish
person it's someone who's scared about
how this is going to impact them and
yeah just to me what love is is when
someone can override that with putting
someone else's needs yep of their own
and and when you talk about when
everyone else walks out of the room and
they walk in its foot there was recently
onto our suicide awareness days man
ironically Twitter would be promoting
that as Twitter's probably one of the
worst places for mental health in the
world but you know it's not about if
reach out if someone tells someone if
you're feeling down and I'm like you
know what we should be giving out advice
for the people who are around those
people because they're the ones who need
a [__] step up well they are the ones
who need to walk into the room because
no one else if loneliness isn't few I
biotech slowness about being there
putting their needs while you're sitting
there feeling like I don't want to be
around this person because they're going
to bring me down because they're feeling
down but their needs before yours you
know I mean that's what I feel like love
is yeah and this this this this love
which you feel from here is not you know
I love you so do what you like to be in
this this this is this is the power this
is the power they want to shut down they
do it through fear they do it through
anxiety and they do it through
depression when you open this up that's
where your power comes from what I did
and what else comes from here intuition
what is intuition intuition knows and
the brain thinks because it doesn't know
and thus it has to try to work it out so
look at the body language of people hold
on I'm thinking I'm thinking I know I
just know law where the hands go I know
I know I just feel it and this is where
intuition comes from and there came a
point maybe about 93 94 where my way of
researching flipped for
looking at the information that was
coming to me and concluding what was
happening which was this story working
it out and it moved here and what has
happened since that period right up to
present day is I know what's happening
here and then the information to support
that follows so on 9/11 I knew what had
happened that's why I started
researching it immediately that it was a
problem reaction solution but as soon as
you've seen the footage soon after it
because I what what I knew before but I
knew it and and then the information has
come ever since to support that and the
reason is that this is our connection to
the wider consciousness this is why this
is innate intelligence because it's
connected to those levels of awareness
that do know this is not thus it's asked
to work it out and there's a an
organization in America it's called the
heart math Institute and it's been
working for decades now on the power of
this and how it influences reality and
there was the lady I think she still
runs it she was the therapist at one
time and she said that the check one of
the techniques she had when she was
talking to a client she she'd put them
in a chair and she'd say tell me you
tell me your problem from your head's
point of view tell me what your head
saying about this problem and she'd
listen and then she'd symbolically
changed chairs and she said well now
tell me what your heart is saying about
the problem and this lady says she it
was like talking to two totally
different people because what they're
doing head to heart is actually
literally connecting with another level
of consciousness which therefore has a
completely different fix on the problem
and I can't stress enough by the way how
right you are from a personal point of
view because I feel like my head is
quite a negative place but my heart is a
very positive place it's like sits in
battle
when they want that's why the hope that
the society structures it is to shut
this down and when you open it you don't
just open it to what we call love you
open it to enormous amounts of insight
intuitive knowing that that you won't
get if that is closed and the other
thing about love you know people think
all we always talking about love and
he's a bloke if we doing the washing-up
next you know what are those things but
this is actually the ultimate power
because love is devoid of them of that
which controls us fear when your heart
is open and you're coming from there you
do not feel fear this never says I know
what I need to do I know what I need to
do that the right thing bar what are the
consequences this doesn't do consequence
is this what are the consequences oh my
god this oh well the consequences for me
this is going I don't give a [__] you
said my dick doesn't really think
trouble it's a completely different
interaction with reality it just
transforms your bloody life not only do
you get massive insights into things
that you wouldn't normally but you chill
out because you realize this is just a
transitory experience it's not
everything knows I wonder got a few
questions left because I don't want to
tickle - I don't get other stuff to do
you got anything like I was just gonna
say if if that is a completely groove
what you're saying if that is what
you're working towards what is the goal
of the Cabal then if if they know this
well why not work towards that that's um
that's a very good question and it's a
very very relevant question especially
for that the young people watching this
hmm there is an end game it has been
working towards it for a long time this
has not been going on for five years or
fifty years with this this goes back
thousands of years and the the key to
increasing human control has been
increasing human centralization of power
so for instance
there was a time when the human race was
made up of tribes and the tribes decided
what happened in the tribe then they
came a big change when lots of tribes
came together under what were called
nations and then a few people at the
center of the nation were now dictating
to all the former tribes that made up
that nation through the European Union
we've gone to the next level which is to
bring the nations together under
centralized control and the idea
eventually is to have a world government
world army world central bank world
currency for cashless with we're heading
to so fast and and underpinning the that
structure of centralized global control
is complete control of human perception
and it's happening in front of our eyes
what why would someone want man if well
I mean why why does why does why does
why does Stalin want to control Russia
with a rod of iron because they're
freaking mad they're Psychopaths and the
the the the the first there's a thing
called the hair test it's a list of
traits and if you have enough of them
your psychopath officially can the top
trait of a psychopath is lack of empathy
the inability to put themselves in the
feelings and the situation they're
making other people suffer and when you
remove empathy all limits go right we're
back to 9/11 only people with no empathy
could possibly do that knowing the
consequences for those people that could
start the second of the first world
second world wars
so that lack of empathy but where they
where this is suddenly that those people
are also very good at what they do
they're very good they're very sick but
intellectually they're very very clever
and they they study and this is what AI
is doing you know they talk about
surveillance and and all this
technological surveillance all this AI
stuff well
it's not just surveillance all the
things that the human race posts on the
internet posts on social media all that
is being fed into AI which is becoming
enormous ly skilled at understanding the
human psyche and therefore able to
manipulate the human psyche to control
what we're back to it control perception
but the end game in terms of complete
control of human perception is to
connect the human brain
- what official intelligence and this is
something I've been warning about now
for so frickin long and the Silicon
Valley crazies are now openly talking
about its Gaia's Guyot - Google was
called a futurist called Ray Kurzweil
and there are others like him as well
and they're actually giving the Year
2034 when which I'm wearing 2019 as we
speak for connecting the human brain to
artificial intelligence and that at that
point and I'm now quoting or
paraphrasing Kurzweil once that
connections made he said AI will do more
and more and more of human thinking
until Yuman thinking as we currently
know it will be basically negligible
right in other words the human mind will
become AI and instead of manipulating
human perception human perception will
become direct through AI and this is how
they've done it they say what we're
already kind of all we are nicer than
the forest on oh yeah what up that I
just want to give you a sequence because
this would be very relevant to the
people watching this you know I talked
about problem reaction solution
there's a nut there's another technique
that is the bedfellow the stablemate of
the problem reaction solution I call it
the totalitarian tiptoe and what you do
is you start an a and you know you're
going to Zed but if you go in too big a
leap to Zed the change is such that
people go what's going on what's going
on sapling so you go as as big a leap as
you can but not so big that people see
the pattern so the totalitarian tiptoe
to control by a I went like this
Stage one get them addicted to
technology that they hold your goal is
to get in the body so first of all stage
one you get them addicted to technology
they hold so we had this explosion of
the smartphone era and before that you
could say yeah even calculators that
kind of thing yeah macaques have you
want technology that goes inside someone
I know a few devices yeah well you buddy
you bloody would yeah but believe me
then they're not addicted in the same so
that's stage one and that's achieved
vast numbers of people are absolutely
addicted to technology they hold you go
to stage two their whole doubles next
stage wearables you going in the body so
next stage you get on the body this is
your Apple watch your Bluetooth and all
these things right endless ad this is
literally not anymore so yes gadgets
that you wear and what they're doing is
conditioning normality they're making
these things normal I'll tell you
something about these office assistants
in a minute about that too and and then
and and these AI bloody duck Barbie
dolls they've given out for kids and
stuff like that so then you go to the
next stage small soldier which is inside
the body which is internal chipping
which I've been saying was the plans is
about 1992 Elon Musk is sort of
beginning oh don't talk to me about him
no no no I really want to hear what you
think about massive attachments out and
says that AI could be the end of the
human race on that he's right and then
he opens a freaking company called
neural link to connect the human brain
to computers yeah and we talked me
through that and sort of Overton Window
sense of the only the only way that they
are going to connect everyone to AI no
matter where they are in the world is by
having they every inch of the planet
covered with Wi-Fi the cloud this is
what Kurzweil says that the human brain
is going to be connected to the cloud so
the cloud has to be global and they are
putting thousands and thousands of
satellites up in orbit that musk one of
the major ones through his company
SpaceX to beam Wi-Fi at the planet so no
one can escape from it are you of the
belief that this 5g thing's massively 5g
is ramping up this whole what they call
Smart Grid do you know notice how
everything today is called Smart hmm
everything everything called Smart is
part of a smart grid and part of that
smart grid is connecting AI to the human
brain so everything is connected by a is
controlled by AI and whoever controls AI
controls everything and from one central
point when this grid is up and running
and it's it's be putting to place more
and more every day all over the world
whoever controls that central point
controls not only you know everything
here technologically controls the human
mind and itself fast things move I
remember some books ago not that long
ago really I was warning about the plan
for something called the Internet of
Things where everything is connected to
the Internet
now already billions of things are
connected to the Internet everything's
connected to AI in the Internet the
internet by the way was made possible
thanks to an organization called DARPA
which is the technological development
arm of the Pentagon and if I called
DARPA evil I would I would be fearful of
of evil suing me for defamation the
character to be honest that's how bad it
is right and so the idea is if you
before you can make a physical
connection to AI and people accept this
you've got to make a psychological
connection and what they're doing and it
because it's all a psychological game
the few cannot control billions unless
they control the psyche of the billions
all it would take for me by the way it's
just a good video game that I could just
play whenever I really when I'm on an
aeroplane or whatever I'll just go like
I would be so easily tricked really I
think the opposite
I mean was it I'm not into technology
not with me in it I mean we love Mary
we're constantly playing game is an
amuse ik whip with fiends for the [__]
you don't gotta say we there already I I
think I I think you'd be first in the
queue you everyone knows if they follow
you on Instagram gobble you're all over
it
you'd be one of the first in the queue I
don't know having said that I love
Marshall McLuhan so I go any further but
I think me I would draw the line at
putting something inside my what if it
was just clicked on the yo-yo just
nowhere so all of a silly idea is to get
absolutely in the brain and not know
probably start with something like yet
oh you're just where well what on you
raced I I was I was speaking in Sweden
last year already at that point more now
3,000 people in Sweden have been
microchipped yeah by their own agree
nearly men probably right yeah I've met
some Swedish women before and they're
just they wouldn't put up with that and
it's one of the reasons is so doors will
open without them pushing them you know
the lazy bastards I mean what's the
point of that anyway because this this
is how they're fabulous is how the the
obsession with that's in the movies
you're in it whether you hold a hand up
or whatever and even demolition man in
the nineties for crises but there is
then there a thing there are things that
go the other way like Doctor Who is the
Cybermen those kind of Inc sort of
warning against that yeah I Robot those
kind of things what you've just
mentioned is and I'll come to the the
office assistants in a minute you know
these echoes and stuff this reason for
them it's not good for Humanity at all
but there's something it says it's a
very very important psychological
manipulation technique is called
pre-emptive programming mmm okay this is
how it works
you are here you want to go there that
society is so dramatically different to
this one you're gonna you're gonna face
a response against it you want to do
what so what you do is you fill the
movies and the programs with storylines
and scenes and portrayals of that world
and so what you're doing and you look at
the movies that have come out in the
last like 10 15 20 years about this
whole
world of technology and robots in AI and
Einstein and needs anything with well
smithing much yeah and what do you call
it that the one with that Tom Cruise oh
yeah yeah minority or Minority Report
you a mission impossible to business yes
and and what you're doing is you're
you're you're preparing the subconscious
particularly self-conscious conscious as
well to become familiar with the world
you want to take people into over so in
them so as the world is brought in for
real
that familiarity is going to lessen the
resistance to it because there's a
familiarity of that going to do it do it
if they make it easier to get laid for
men that is the tender via like you know
microchip do you know the worry is David
you're laughing he's totally smell
there's one way you'll get men to go
along with this yeah as if you make it
easy I get women guaranteed Duns and I
shouldn't be saying this because I'm
giving them ideas yeah but to be fair
Brian to be fair if you've had the idea
I think they've had the idea for this is
point yeah you got to get people
familiar with AI and interacting with it
as if it's human heart of life in it as
if it's human and that's what the office
assistants before some people have one
in every bloody room I've come across
they're interacting with them as if the
a is aisle excellence yeah well that
stuff as if the energy as if the AI
voice is is human and and then you've
got the the Barbie dolls and these
others remember rocky who had the little
thing that took the floor up forum
Sylvester Stallone in Rocky yeah yeah
yeah we're talking like early 90s I
didn't even it was in the movies though
you know when you interact do you
interact with any of these things have
you actually I've gotten a boulder
tonight or does it why because it scares
you or because I don't I don't want him
I don't need him so you see the thing is
that when people become addicted to
something like technology hmm they think
they need it but they don't necessarily
need it I mean III don't carry a
smartphone I have one at home which
comes out about once every six months
its
three G one when I have to be somewhere
and contacted and there's nowhere they
were to contact him here and what I say
is okay I'll call you from a landline
and our final an line is as much as I
use it maybe three or four times a year
for you know one small amount of times
apart from that I don't use that kind of
technology
I think it's healthier yeah but what
it's doing to me it's it's creating
especially with the kids and these a I
connected Barbie dolls and stuff it's
making them familiar with AI to the
point where they perceive it as human
and once they've got that acceptance and
that interaction then when they move
into connected to here yeah again you
can have far less resistance because the
it's not they all my god kind of
reactions no chakra it's no shot it's
become part of life by then and that's
why they're targeting the kids now
because they are gonna be the adults
twenty thirty when they really want this
to come in full-blown easier for us and
that's a good thing I've got two
questions left just to finish up on that
min so the people in the Cabal would
they be connected to the AI or would
like is their goal to get everyone
connected as one remember the Riddler
and Batman well you sort of stuck it on
his head and sometimes you're trying to
make a good point and the yeah I'm
Carrie
yeah but you're doing the worst Batman
TV it was like main controller and it
would all go over their head it was what
this reminds me it was the worst Batman
but the I know you're gonna say yeah the
inner core will not be connected to us
so they'll be almost elves night they'll
be controlling it right okay so their
goal is not for good and what what is
the point of controlling it then is that
to have a work force what it because
once you've got it well is it a toy what
it's another it's it that's another
question that I've answered in the books
but it's it's another long answer okay
which we never drink after yeah well I'd
love to do another one after this
actually because I found your fuss in it
and so there's only two questions I've
got left one would be how old are you
Ken David sixty seven right six seven
years old me I often think I've got life
sewn up I'm at a point now my life
I've got a good beat on things and then
I realize a year later I had no [__]
clue a year ago and I was just wondering
what point of your life after everything
you've been through did you experience
the the biggest growth of your life
where you felt that you learned most
about life and yourself and everywhere
it's been an ongoing thing was there
only with that stands oh well the thing
that stands out was the mass ridicule
because that opened the door you see
some of the things I've written and
talked about which which at the time of
the ridicule I didn't know I was gonna
be writing and talking about anyone who
has any concern about what people think
of them is never gonna write and talk
about yeah because people were saying me
when you talked about this did you think
that you get ridicule and you thought I
think June I'd work that out you know I
mean this is really gonna piss them off
yeah yeah yeah I've worked that out if I
say that I'm gonna get ridicule yeah I
think I had work that out but the point
is because of that clearing out of fear
of what other people think you say
anyway
and the what you find in life is you can
follow the herd by staying within the
norms or you can go on your own path and
and if that if your own path has
validity the world starts coming towards
you instead of you following the world
and interest in my work is absolutely
exploded in the last few years
explode here you've got millions of
views on YouTube and of course you know
I'm shadow band like crazy as well
through algorithms so it doesn't go out
as much I think the thing with you it I
mean this wasn't make the zero money
that's what the YouTube will do they'll
make sure there's no money on this it
will be so if everyone should appreciate
it even more for that reason go mad yeah
my right way to monetize like crazy yeah
good and my last question then would be
how would you like to be remembered Khan
Kellis I like that because I will be
exploring forever forever by then me
like is one of the best
that question being a pleasure
I hope everyone I started it it's been
absolutely a real pleasure it's a big
table David so yeah to everyone who
wants to check the book out we will put
the link in the docket jumper law yeah
there's other book I think it's worth
saying this isn't his first definitely
there's other book and it's ours last
he's got a YouTube channel of his own
yeah yeah just for anyone who is
interested in sort of getting into David
Icke where would you start book wise I
start with Ellen
brilliant champion don't forget to like
the video subscribe thanks for watching
and we'll see you later
Cheers cheers mate I love very much that
was great I loved it yeah